Candid Truth.
What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it. And I got my good
friend here, Josh, with us today. We're
going to have a good little discussion
because this always comes up. I cannot
believe it because when I first heard
it, I was like, man, this is some corner
of the earth niche thing that we are in
the little season of Satan who's going
out to deceive the entire world. What do
you think about that, man? So, I'm so
glad you came on, dude. I'm so glad that
you've studied this out and we can talk
about this because I'm interested. I I
want to know the truth, bro. Yeah, it's
a blessing to be talking about this
because this is not a topic to take
lightly. And it's not one to start to
research and then just start teaching
the world about because you have to be
careful with how you understand
Revelation, where we are in time, and
what people are preparing for. Are we
preparing for the first resurrection or
are we preparing to just simply not
attack the camp of the saints? Those are
two different things. And overall, when
you know, you talk about this to people,
you get two reactions. Either they don't
even know what you're talking about when
you say little season or they've done
hours and hours worth of internet
research, watching videos, looking at
some Bible verses. And so, this is one
of those things you need to always first
pray for the Holy Spirit to guide your
understandings. I was um looking into
this years ago without any understanding
of what was going to come about with the
internet and people talking about this
topic. I was getting um emails from a
friend and so it's it's extremely easy
to go that direction if you don't
understand prophecy. Prophecy is what
will keep you rooted in the truth with
this and knowing all the precursors.
What are the things that is going to
happen? What was the Messiah saying?
because his words are what people are
using to say that he's already came,
right? It can seem like that. So, you
have to look at the context really,
really closely. It's again, this is not
something to take lightly. Even, you
know, the book of Revelation ends by
saying anyone, you know, who's changing
the words of this book, this specific
book, takes away, they can have their
name removed out of the book of life.
And so if you're saying, you know, that
something in Revelation didn't happen or
didn't happen the way it was said to
happen, that's a big deal. Lots of
precurs are going to happen. And we are
in significant times. It's easy to see
with all the stuff that's going on, the
powers of darkness being unleashed. And
so when you hear little season, you
think, oh my goodness, the enemy is
deceiving the whole world. That's what
it feels like we're in. But we are
essentially, the way I see it, we are in
the long season, which there's time
period. It's exactly the same. The
purpose of the enemy is the same. What
is it? Deceive the world. You know, to
attack a threat, a threat from above in
the long season, Armageddon, all of
that. The little season is simply, which
we'll go over it. Um, you're trying to
attack a camp of the saints that's
already here and it happens after what
we call the millennial reign. And the
misleading part about calling the reign
the millennial reign is that it's not
just a millennium. The reign never ends.
Very good point. Never going to end. It
is a kingdom that once it's established,
it's not going to go away and hide. It's
going to be there and there's going to
be some things in motion. So,
understanding based on prophecy what's
going to be happening, all the
precursors that will help add some
clarity, but it is a rather convincing
idea that we're in that little season.
And there's some there's some key
evidence that you have to go through and
find out why it's not true. And so,
we'll be doing that. And if you are in
the camp of believing we're in the
little season, be at peace. I'm not here
to attack you or your integrity or
anything like that. It's just go over
things that brought me clarity because
the spirit led me a different direction
looking at our prophetic timeline from
creation. We have that seven days aspect
with six days being creation days and
the seventh day being a day of rest. And
from all that I can see and all that
we've gathered, we're about to enter
that seventh millennial day. And there's
so many prophecies about that. that it's
so interconnected. And so we are in
significant times, but I believe we're
preparing for the deception, the false
return, the lawless one, and then of
course the resurrection, Armageddon, all
that stuff is around the corner. And so
knowing where we are in time is a big
deal. Yeah. So, if you if this sounds
like total like what are these guys even
talking about because you never heard
this. Um there's a time in the book of
Revelation where it talks about that
there's going to be um basically there's
the millennial reign. I mean, it's not
really in the Bible specifically quoted
like that, but after the thousand years
is finished. So, that's what it says.
After the thousand years is finished,
Satan will have to be sure uh loosed for
a short time because he's bound for a
thousand years. Satan's bound and for a
thousand years he's unable to do
anything. But after the thousand years
is finished, he's loosed. And a lot of
people don't even know why he's loosed.
Why is he why would why would God loose
Satan after all this time of perfect uh
harmony and all this stuff even that is
a confusing topic, but I don't want to
get into that like the nuances of the
millennial reign. But um so people
believe that right now we are in that
time of Satan's little season which
means that Christ came back a thousand
plus years ago because the only way you
can be in Satan's little season is after
the thousand years is finished. Satan's
loosed again. So how so for that
means Jesus came back a thousand or more
years ago. We're in this season that
Satan's deceiving. And that's why you
see uh the governments are so corrupt
and Hollywood is pushing satanic agendas
so much because we're in that time.
We're we're in that that season. But how
does that even make sense? Because if
Christ returns, there's we're all, you
know, all the believers are supposed to
be immortal, right? Where are they at?
Where is Jesus at? And I don't know if
we're going to get into some of that,
like where are they at? Oh, yeah.
But if you guys don't know who this
brother right here on the screen is,
Josh, go check out Founded Earth
Brothers. Got a
amazing videos, documentaries,
interviews. Go check out his stuff, man.
There's some really cool research in
there. Especially if you are someone who
doesn't know where you stand about the
shape of the earth and things like that.
There's a lot of good stuff on there,
man. and you you can just binge watch
turn off Netflix and go check out
Founded Earth Brothers.
Thanks. Thanks, Mikey.
So, here's your presentation, bro. This
is the floor is yours. Let's get
started, guys, because this is something
that needs to first be defined before
you know, we have a wide range of
people. I'm sure we have Bible scholars
in the crowd. We have people that have
been researching this for a couple
years. And then we have people who've
never heard of it. And so I'm going to
break it down real simple and try not to
be too long-winded. I have a few hundred
slides. I'm going to skip past many of
them just for the sake of time. A few
hundred. Yeah, I have a few hundred, but
we will only go over the ones that are
important. And one that I feel is
important is actually reading the verse
about that little season. Mikey was just
talking about it. This is Revelation
chapter 20. And it says, "And I saw an
angel come down from heaven." This is
John reading uh seeing things future
events. Having the key of the bottomless
pit and a great chain in his hand. And
he laid hold on the dragon that old
serpent which is the devil and Satan and
bound him a thousand years and cast him
into the bottomless pit and shut him up
and set a seal upon him that he should
deceive the nations no more till the
thousand years should be fulfilled. and
after that he must be loose a little
season. And so that's where people think
we are. They believe that John wrote
Revelation. And I was under the
impression that he wrote it in like 90
AD.
Well, the the common theme is I'm
assuming he wrote this after all this
resurrection happened. if he wrote it in
90 AD because many say that the return
happened in 70 AD like not long after
they're going around being persecuted
trying to spread the news that that's
when it happened. That's one variety of
the view. There's other versions. I
don't want to get into them in too great
a detail. But a lot of people believe
that this is all happened somehow. And
so right here when you keep reading in
Revelation, this is where you start
talking about the millennial reign. He
says, "I saw the souls of them that were
beheaded for the witness of Jesus and
for the word of God, and which had not
worshiped the beast, neither his image,
neither had received his mark upon their
foreheads or in their hands. And they
lived and reigned with Christ a thousand
years." Hallelujah. That's what I'm
wanting to prepare for there. Living and
reigning for a thousand years. It says,
"But the rest of the dead live not
again." So there's going to be another
judgment until the thousand years were
finished. This is the first
resurrection. Blessed and holy is he
that hath part in the first
resurrection. On such the second death
hath no power, but they shall be priests
of Yahw and of Christ, and shall reign
with him a thousand years. And after
that thousand years, the rain doesn't
stop. It's still going on. But the enemy
is let loose. There's people when you
have this
resurrection. There's going to be some
unique things happening. And so, we're
going to be talking about that. The uh
people, there is going to be an
Armageddon event. We'll get into
Armageddon, but I want to read this
right here. Um is that actually I think
I have that. Never mind. I have that on
my other slide. And so, we're going to
talk about
Armageddon when Satan is loosed right
here in verse seven. out of his prison
and shall go out to deceive the nations
which are in the four quarters of the
earth. So he's out. What's his purpose
here? It's to deceive the nations. And
he is deceiving them for a purpose.
There's only one purpose here. And it
says the quart four quarters of the
earth, Gog and Magog, to gather them
together to battle the number of whom is
at the sand of the sea. And they went up
on the breath of the earth and compassed
the camp of the saints about and the
beloved city and fire came down from God
out of heaven and devoured them. And so
you're like, "Wait a minute. How is
there a camp of the saints or
resurrection? Who are these people
outside the camp?" Well, the first
resurrection people that have their
glorified body, they're reigning with
the Messiah. They're not outside the
camp. There's going to be people who
survive Armageddon. They're going to
come into play later on. That's going to
be another proof that we aren't a bunch
of people who have survived Armageddon.
There's a reason for that. There's
things that happen in Armageddon that
are powerful. And so, the entire goal of
the enemy during that time is to get the
entire world to believe. Look at this
camp of the saints over there. And it's
a pattern with the enemy. When you look
back to Egypt, what did he do? He got
the Egyptians to go after the most high
saints that were with him, his people,
Israel. Look, we can take them. They're
surrounded by water. Ignore the pillar
of fire. Let's just march right on. You
know, like the enemy is crafty. He can
get people to do this way back when that
just watched the hand of God unleash all
these plagues and they were foolish
enough to do it then with the waters
even in mid part. Like imagine these two
walls of water and you going through
them. And so it was too late. And that's
the goal of the enemy. He doesn't he he
he might promise people eternal life and
all these rewards in the world and all
these lies and sell your soul, you'll
get this type of stuff, but he's as many
as he can to destruction doing it right
now. We're witnessing that everywhere we
look. But according to the the word, you
have these two different deceptions that
are very similar. You have first the one
that's going on right now, the spirits
of devils working miracles. This is in
chapter 16 of Revelation. Which go forth
unto the kings of the earth and of the
whole world to gather them to battle or
to the battle of that great day of God
Almighty. This sounds very similar to
what we just read. What are these evil
doing? They're going to the kings of the
earth. Why kings? Why not nations like
you see in chapter 20? Well, when the
Most High is here, there's not going to
be any more kings. There's not going to
be any more presidents. When the Most
High and his beloved are here reigning,
they're not going to be worried about
who's president. We're going to have the
King of Kings on the earth. We won't
have a Donald Trump and all of that.
It's not be like that. There's going to
be things they're doing precursors to
this. They're going to be when the camp
is set up every year, if you want rain,
it says in prophecy, we'll go over all
that. Um people are going to be going to
the um the city, the beloved city to
keep the feast of tabernacles. somebody
from each nation. If somebody doesn't do
that, then your nation's not going to
get rain. And so, one good way I make
people mad is to get them to forget
about it, distract them, give them some
new distraction, make them forget to go
and keep the feast, maybe change the
times, confuse them. Then they start not
getting rain, they're going to get mad
and want to attack. There's there's lots
of different tactics the enemy could
use. But we are in what I believe right
here, the evil ones doing the same
stuff. They're deceiving and getting
people ready to attack the threat from
above. And that's why Mikey, you've
talked about the alien threat. They are
preparing us for a threat from above.
With every movie we watch, all these
different, not every, lots of movies.
And I find this interesting. We hear
about the unclean spirits like frogs
coming out of the mouth. They just
resurrected an extinct species of frog
that literally gives birth to live young
out of it. Oh, dude, that's crazy.
Coming out of the mouth. Like what are
the chances they would do that right
now? This thing's been extinct since
1980s. And they're like, "Let's bring it
back." I didn't know that existed, by
the way. But there it is. Popped up.
Really? That's pretty cool. Probably
something prophetic foreshadowing what's
going on here. And so, kings of the
earth, like we just read, where's the
threat from above? Where are we going to
meet the Messiah? In the air. We're
going to be up there. I believe when
there's the threat from above, I believe
the first resurrected are going to be
there. That trumpet's going to sound
God. That's going to be a powerful sound
and it's going to be a resurrecting
power, breath of life blown out of that
trumpet. You're going to see something
spectacular. But people that aren't
resurrected, they're going to be looking
up. What's going on? You know, like what
is this? Well, it's a threat from above.
It's the one we've been warning you
about. You know, that type of
programming you've talked about. That's
what they want us to get geared up for.
They're not showing all these Hollywood
movies with a threat from the ground,
some kingdom hidden somewhere. It's
always
And so right here in Revelation 16,
you're going to see what happens at
Armageddon. It says here that the
seventh angel poured out his vial into
the air. And there came a great voice
out of the temple of heaven from the
throne, saying, "It is done." And there
were voices and thunders and lightnings.
And there was a great earthquake such as
was not since men were upon the earth so
mighty an earthquake and so great. And
the great city was divided into three
parts. And the cities of the nations
fell. And great Babylon came in
remembrance before God to give unto her
the cup of the wine of her fierceness of
his wrath. And every island fled away.
And the mountains were not found. Think
about that. Still seeing some good old
and there's no more sea, right? Yeah. It
says right here, there fell upon men
great hell out of heaven. And this is
one where you kind of picture hell
stones like the storms we have. But it
says every stone about the weight of a
talent. Imagine out of heaven, not out
of the clouds, out of heaven, out of the
firmament. And so the weight of a
talent, that's about 100 pounds to put
that into perspective. And so their
little underground bunkers are not going
to help them when they have the largest
earthquakes we've ever experienced.
Hellstones 100 pounds are going to smash
through skyscrapers. Like this is pretty
big. And it says, "And then what did
they do? They blasphemed God because of
the plague of the hell, for the plague
thereof was exceeding great." Same thing
that you see in Egypt. What happened in
Egypt? What was one of the plagues?
Hell, massive amounts of hell with fire
on the ground. When you look to Gog and
Magog, you're going to see the fire on
the ground aspect. Things are prophetic
in the word. And so massive hellbones
about two and a half pounds as the world
record. But smaller than that, you're
seeing this kind of damage here. Imagine
100 pounds. These are just a pound. So
just imagine them laying around. I mean,
huge, huge, huge hailstones. I couldn't
imagine how big that would be coming
down from above. People would definitely
be terrified. And so right here in uh
Revelation 16, you're further on, you're
going to see what happens. Those unclean
spirits, it says, "I saw three unclean
spirits like frogs come out of the mouth
of the dragon." This is where they're
gathering them to a place. And it tells
you um where they're coming from. It
says, "Out of the mouth of the dragon,
out of the mouth of the beast, out of
the mouth of the false prophet. They are
spirits of devils working miracles which
go forth. I think I already read this
one to the kings of the earth and the
whole world. They're gathering them
together essentially for this battle.
They're trying to prepare the world to
battle God Almighty. And right here in
the bottom, I highlighted it. It says,
"And he gathered them together into a
place called in the Hebrew tongue
Armageddon." Armageddon. If you look it
up in the word, it's mentioned in Joshua
as Megiddo. Pronounced a little
differently. That's the where it's hard
to find stuff because Old and New
Testament coming from different
manuscripts. You'll have different
wording, different spellings, but that's
what that is. It's mentioned in there a
couple times in Joshua, even in the book
of Judges. And so, Megiddo, what is this
place? It's an actual location. It's
owned by the United Nations. Wow. So,
they own
Armageddon. And they got the real world
map there surrounded by the Roman little
um leaves. You know, they have to add
the Romans. Yeah. That's the laurel
wreath.
Yeah. Straight out of Rome. And so
UNESCO, they own a lot of things. They
own the pyramids, the ruins of Babylon,
Jesuit missions, Stonehenge, lots of
things that are important to them. What
is the UNESCO?
Um, United Nations. Um, what's it
called? United Nations. Something
something with the UN. I forget those
last letters. United Nations. Chat
probably knows. I never heard of it. But
this is like um so the United Nations
own each of those things meaning the the
nations together like I don't know like
anytime people start asking me questions
like what do you think
about China and Russia and all that I'm
like dude in my opinion they're all the
same like where the United Nations like
they plan all the wars and everything.
Yeah. They're in the land. If you look
at old biblical maps, Russia and China
are kind of in the land of Gog and Magog
type of area. And
Armageddon is right there on the map.
You can see it right there next to
Syria. And this place, if you kind of go
based on the book of Jubilees telling
you where these lands are because these
lands were were given to the children of
Noah. Um, but Gog and Magog is up north,
I believe, and northeast of the River
Tina. And so I just kind of tried to
point to it a general direction. I don't
know exactly where it would be. Mhm. But
right about there.
And what's fascinating, remember when we
had the so-called um shutdown with the
whole country shut down? I don't want to
talk about certain words. I don't want
to get you flagged, but um had a certain
event like a rehearsal before it
happened. And most people in movement
know what I'm talking about. Well, they
just had in 2024 something very similar.
And this was what looked like a
rehearsal for Armageddon. They had the
steadfast defender operation going on.
And this is something huge. They got the
NATO's allied forces involved. All these
people came to the Euro or Euroatlantic
area which is right there at the land of
Armageddon. I mean, it's right there
near it. And so that Euroatlantic area,
they went there and they brought, let me
see if I can show you the Euroatlantic
area right up there in blue. Right there
near the land of Armageddon. And they
brought 90,000 personnel from all of the
31 allies that they had. Look how many
ships and stuff they had. 80 plus air
platforms, 50 naval assets, 1100 combat
vehicles, 166 tanks. Like they had the
works. They were rehearsing something.
And they called that something a
nearpeer threat. They didn't say
terrorist. They didn't say the normal
language. They said a nearpeer threat is
what they're practicing for. And this
was last year. And so right there and
this was like uh multiple nations that
went. Yeah. Oh my goodness. All of NATO
31. So we're already getting to that
point where I don't know if I'm real
loud. I just peeked out on there. Um
we're already getting to the point
where all the militaries of the world
are coming together. When we when you're
reading Revelation 16 or 20, I can't
remember about the three frogs. It says
that they're going to go to the kings of
the earth. These demons, these uh
unclean spirits are going to go to the
militaries, the kings and the militaries
of the world and unite them together.
And here we see they're united together
ready for
battle. That's that should be shocking
to anyone. Like if you are not a Bible
believer, man, like everything is being
fulfilled and clearly time is close.
very close and and this right here when
it was happening I was like wow this was
when I was in the heat of my research
and I'm like they're preparing for a
battle and the news is always making
that alien stuff come to the forefront
and you're seeing it like the stuff
you've been pointing out with the alien
stuff is very eye opening because it's
showing you more of a spiritual aspect
of it now you're seeing the demonic
aspect of it and they're deceiving the
kings of the earth and so the leaders
the presidents the people that would be
classified as kings they're going to be
deceived who? And I know we all want
them to be our saviors and to make the
country great and do all these different
things they're going to do, but
Revelation tells us they're going to be
deceived. Maybe not all of them. You
know, he may be able to use one for a
great purpose. So, I don't want to say
they're all bad, but they are going to
be deceived according to Revelation,
many of them. And they're going to be
gathering together to battle. And that's
what we see here. They're gathering
together to practice for a threat.
Imagine that. That's expensive. That's
millions upon millions, if not billions
of dollars, getting that much military
equipment and personnel to a certain
spot. What do they do? They go around
firing these cannons. Like what? When
they get there, they're like, "We just
want to see how long it took us to get
there, you know?" So, here's a question.
Even for somebody that doesn't believe
the Bible, why are all the nations
coming together to to prepare for a
battle? Who are they going to fight? you
obviously you have all the n you're not
going to fight against another nation.
You're going to come together to fight
something. So, it's either going to be
Christ or it's either going to be an
alien invasion or whatever, which if
you've watched this channel long enough,
you know, we don't believe that that is
true. That there that the quote unquote
alien invasion is a demonic deception.
That there is no outer space. There is
no things coming in through the
firmament that Genesis talks about.
Yeah. And that's that's the threat.
That's where it's got to be though. It's
got to be from above, not below. Yeah.
With Armageddon. And it's a long season.
The enemy is going to have a long time
to prepare a narrative. And we look at
how long they've worked to get us to all
forget where we came from, what we live
on, like all the things they've done.
It's taken them years and little bitty
pieces here and there. You know,
Capernicus coming in, somebody else
coming along and inventing the Big Bang,
somebody else pushing the sun further
away. They've had a long time to work on
this. And none of our ancestors that I
know of were ever going to the new
Jerusalem, this the beloved city to keep
the feast of tabernacles. But they're
going to gather people together to say,
"Look, they're they're just a bunch of
priests in there. They're not ready for
war. We can take them out. We can put
all this we could get your freedom, you
know, lawlessness. We you don't have to
go and keep that feast anymore and we'll
take care of you. Let's go." And people
are going to fall for it. And so the
deceptive powers are just that we have
to be humble and know they've they've
been doing this over and over again for
many years. They aren't they're not like
mankind. Mankind couldn't pull off the
deceptions they're doing on their own.
They need powers of darkness and they
work hand in hand with these powers of
darkness. And so Revelation 20, we
already read that. I'm not going to read
it again, but that's that fire coming
down. When they go, remember Armageddon,
hell's coming down from above. Massive
hellstones. with Gog and Magog, it's
fire from above. And then you have the
final judgment. And so that is it. We're
not preparing right now for that
attacking the camp of the saints because
it's not here. And the common thought is
it's it moved after the thousand years.
the camp just went away and now it's at
the North Pole as a a common answer that
I get and and I know why they say that
because they'll there's a verse there's
some verses that talk about the center
of the navl of the earth or the center
of the earth and when they hear that if
you don't know where prophecy tells you
it's going to be you'll go center of the
earth and you think of the flat earth
map and you go that's the north pole
well earth was just dry land he didn't
say the center of the world the coldest
part of the world you know darkness
because there's darkness up north. His
light is going to be the light of the
world when he's here. You're not going
to need that sun and the moon. It's
always going to be light where they are.
So, that's interesting questions. Um I I
have never looked into that. I just
assumed it would be the North Pole, too,
underneath the northern star and stuff
like that. Yeah. Um and I figured by the
time Christ returns, there's not going
to
be ice and stuff, you know? We're not
going to have those types of seasons and
stuff. There's not going to be death.
So, there's not going to be fall.
There's not going to be Well, the
firmament part's like a scroll when they
when the return happens. So, you're
seeing something's happening to the
firmament that's going to be obvious and
stars are going to be falling like figs,
you know, like it's going to be you're
not going to miss it. Like there's not
going to be a writer a hundred years
later that's like Joephus and he's not
saying and he didn't see the return, you
know, he didn't see the Messiah. And
that's why the Messiah says if somebody
tells you I'm in the desert, don't
believe them. You know, right? He didn't
have time. all the other places. Hey, if
they say I'm in the North Pole, don't
believe them. If they say I'm here,
don't believe. He's saying if they tell
you I'm in a geographic location, don't
believe them. Everyone's going to see
him. And Revelation confirms that. Every
eye will see the return. They're not
going to miss it. It's going to be the
biggest spectacular event. Fearsome for
many, glorious for those who are in that
first resurrection. They're not worried
about the hellstones. I'm I'm sure
there's still people in here that are
just like, "How could anybody believe
that we're in that time?" because we're
not actually gonna go through all the
proofs that, you know, if you watch some
of these videos, you could watch hours
of videos of why people think we're in
the Little Season uh because of
forgotten history during the dark ages
and mud, flood, tartaria, and all this
stuff. Like there's there's actually
buildings that are like underground. And
so there I really don't know how that
all plays in, but there's there's
architecture that's out there that's so
intricate and just amazing that you look
at it, you're like, we couldn't do that
today. How did people do that a thousand
years ago or whatever? So this is why
they think I guess they believe that
that was built during the kingdom of
Christ and it's still here today or
something. But something that just hit
me, the the thing that people always say
is there's so many verses in the Bible
that say, "The end is at hand. I'm at
the door." And all this stuff that it
makes it sound like Jesus is coming soon
back in his day, right? And so they're
like, "Oh, does at hand mean 2,000
years?" And they scoff at that. But I
would like to say in the same
breath, the Bible does say it's a little
season. If this happened in 70 AD, I'm
I'm bad with math. What are we like over
2,000 years, right? So, well, they say
they didn't a thousand years or they've
added a thousand years. So, we're not
really 2,000 years past. Yeah. It's only
beenundred and I don't know or a,200
years. I don't even know how long they
say we're into the little season. That's
still not a little season either. So you
it's kind of like um you can't have it
both ways. You can't say at uh you know
even at the doors and at hand can't be
2,000 years but a little season is 2,000
years. Yeah. Yeah. Little season is
hundreds of years and and and there is
resets there. There has been times,
remember, they're trying to convince us
we came from fish, you know, or a cell
that turned into a fish that turned into
a monkey that or turned into actually,
I'm sorry, a dinosaurs and all these
different things and multi-, you know,
100,000 pound creatures that went
extinct and then turned into birds.
Like, they have all these lies that they
mix in there. And if if we have ancient
civilizations with free energy and
technology, of course they're going to
take that out. They're going to make us
buy their stuff that's poisonous to us,
you know, to use for energy. We're
basically burning stuff that's energy.
We think that's really just adding
toxins to the air. Like they don't want
us having what we can have. And if
people get too advanced, yeah, of
course, great resets, they happen.
They've probably happened many, many
times. The flood was a big reset. And a
lot of the stuff you see buried in mud
is because that flood really was not
that long ago. It wasn't millions of
years ago. Yeah. Good. I'm trying to
find some of the just the little
timeline here. And this is the timeline
that I believe we're on. When you look
at everything in terms of millennial
days, you guys remember Adam died when
he was less than a thousand years old.
And the book of Jubilees says that he
died before he reached a thousand
because in the testimony of the heavens
a thousand years to the most high is as
a day. And so you have that millennial
day and it says for that reason he did
not live out the day of those years. He
didn't live to be a thousand. He died
before that. And so referring to when
the father said uh in the day you eat
that you will die but he didn't die in a
day he died a thousand years is as a day
type thing right. Yeah. And so it made
the enemy when I was younger reading
that going wow the serpent was kind of
right because he didn't die and God said
he would die but when you look at the
book of Jubilees it clarifies that it
was a millennial day aspect. And then
you see other prophets talking about
that. Peter says, "Be mindful of this
that a day is as a thousand years with
the most high and a thousand years as a
day." Like he he makes it he says, "Be
mindful of this." You know, and or be
mindful of the prophets and understand
this, you know, he wanted them to fully
understand that aspect. And they did
back then. We we're starting to gain
sight of it again. I think a lot of
people saw the Messiah 2030 video. It
talked about a lot of these prophetic
things that happened. And um it's
extremely powerful because Hosea, he
prophesied on the fourth millennial day,
he said um after two days he's going to
revive us. On the third day, he's going
to raise us up. Well, when you look at
millennial days, the Messiah came right
there at the beginning of that fifth
millennial day. We're at the ending of a
the new second day. We're about to enter
that third day Hosea was speaking of
where we get raised up, the
resurrection. So, seventh millennial
dayly approaching. Yeah, you're you're
kind of rushing through this chart. I
just want to make sure if anybody I've
I've heard it, you know, I I don't know
whether I can believe it or not. I think
it it's interesting and it could very
well be true. Um but just so people
understand, there's verses that say a
day is as a thousand years in God's
time. And so, uh the earth is roughly
6,000 years of what we've always heard.
And so you're saying at the end of this
6,000th year, we will start the
um like the prophetic Sabbath, basically
the thousand years of peace, which is
the millennial reign. Yeah. And go back
to Genesis. Genesis tells you in chapter
2, it says, and this is weird. I never I
don't know how I glossed over this. It
says, "These are the generations of the
heavens and the earth." Right after it
talks about the Sabbath. Okay, so you
got to remember it says seventh day he
rested and all of that and blessed the
Sabbath. Then it says these are the
generations of the heavens and the earth
when they were created. That's unique
word. These are the generations of the
heaven and the earth when they were
created. So a seven-day generation type
of deal. What's going on there? And so I
believe it's those millennial days being
foreshadowed in that. And not only that,
when he he gives us this guide book, his
word when when the first trumpet,
because we're waiting on the last
trumpet, when did the first trumpet
happen? It happened on the third
millennial day. When the Messiah came at
the end of that fourth millennial day,
our calendar started over. You see it
says 0 AD, right? Yep. Those prophecies
in Hosea happened, he didn't he didn't
even know probably that they were going
to change the calendars when the Messiah
came. And so now we started over zero to
a thousand. That's the first millennial
day. Second millennial day. We're about
to approach approach the third
millennial day which is also the seventh
millennial day. And so it's very
prophetic when our father does
something. It's leaving us guidance and
understanding in his word. And so he
came down with the clouds of heaven. How
does the Messiah say? He's coming down
at the right hand of power with the
clouds of heaven. You know, so it's it's
going to be powerful. It's going to be
very much like it was. Those clouds were
there for a reason. so that the people
wouldn't peer through, see the most
high, his glory, and die, you know, and
so very, very powerful upcoming events.
And so, I want to look at just some of
the prophecies about that. Here's the
one in Hosea. He says, "After two days,
will he revive us?" We're being revived
right now, guys. And in the third day,
will raise us up and we shall live in
his sight. Hallelujah. Dude, that's
crazy. It's really cool. And look when
he said it. He said it right there in
that fourth millennial day. And we are
now approaching the seventh, which is
the new third day, but the seventh day
is still the seventh day, even though
it's on our calendars, the Gregorian
calendar. So what what is that? What
would anybody who's not thinking on this
timeline think about that verse? I mean,
what what is he referring to? Just
people never prophecy can't come true.
According to the Little Season
narrative, prophecy is not a real a big
like foundation for it. It's a lot of
mud, flood, tartaria, things that Jesus
said. And we'll we'll try to get into
that. The prophecies where I I've asked
I have begged I've said send me
prophecies that have come true that back
this up and I'm not seeing a lot of
that. Not that someone can't I just have
it's been absent and and I I've asked
for it. And people will get mad. They
could say things they they they get very
angry. And usually what I could find
when when there's truth, there's a
spirit of love and peace. when there's a
lie, there's anger and attacks and you
just haven't studied you. Your
controllers won't let you say this.
You're an Illuminati puppet or
something. It's just slander and
attacks. And I'm like, just send me
lovingly send me verses and I will
lovingly read them. But I've only had
one person send me verses and it's the
ones that um I had studied and looked at
and and do seem convincing that oh my
goodness, he was talking to the people
then that when they die then some of
them will still be alive and it's going
to happen. Are you going to talk about
that verse? Yeah, I want to try to bring
those up. Cool. And so, um, millennial
rain would have happened on their
calendar around the fifth millennial
day. So, it wouldn't have been on the
seventh millennial day like I I believe
we are about to approach. So, that's
about where it would be roughly on their
calendar. Here's a picture I took from
one of their videos. So, you can see
they have it happening very early on.
Not quite. Um, wait, those arrows you
put there, right? Yeah, I put those
arrows there. Um, those are actually
meant to be on another slide. I don't
know why they're showing up here. Oh,
okay. That is They believe we are here.
I don't believe Oh, actually, yeah, I'm
sorry. Yeah, I'd put those arrows there.
Um, I believe we're before Christ
millennial reign. So, that's why I have
that arrow there. I was confused by
timeline. If anybody's in the in the
video and are really confused, me and
Josh both agree that we are not in
Satan's little season, but we are two
very open-minded people. I mean, I'm as
openminded as I come. Oh, yeah. I'm
extremely open to it. If it's true, I
want to find the truth. I don't want be
a false teacher. And if we're trying to
just avoid attacking the camp of the
saints, that's all our purpose is. Like
it's a different purpose. And in the
Bible, they talk about people who were
saying back then the resurrection
already happened. And Paul was warning
people like, "Hey, there's people going
around saying the resurrection's already
happened. They're already they're
overturning people's faith by saying
that." And so it was a big deal then.
And if it hasn't happened, it's a big
deal now because it does away with the
prophets. And I'm not going to read all
of this. I want to be mindful of you
guys time. But you can screenshot this,
go through. This is Isaiah chapter 2.
Um, during that millennial reign period,
you see the prophets telling us things.
And one of those things is there's going
to be no war during that thousand-y year
time period. Remember, the enemy is
bound. No war. We have nowhere in
history a thousand years of peace. And
so through the videos, well, some
calamities happened during the
thousand-y year period. Um, and there
and there always has to be some sort of
calamity because there there's been wars
going on forever. And yeah, they even
say the dark ages where we lost a
thousand years of time. We don't we
can't explain anything. Even that was
full of war. I mean, they were killing
anyone that didn't bow to the pope and
stuff. So, I mean, I don't know. Yeah,
that's a really good point. Yeah. And
they're they're turning it says their
weapons or their uh swords into
plowshares. They're basically taking
their weapons of war, turning them into
things they can use for farming. out.
You don't need to use those metals to um
attack the most high. You know, like
you're using these metals for good now.
And it says here, I highlighted the blue
part. All nations shall flow unto it.
Talking about the Lord's house where
it's established on the top of the
mountains, and shall be exalted above
all the hills, and all nations shall
flow unto it, and many people shall go
and say, "Come ye and let us go up to
the mountain of Yahweh and to the house
of the God of Jacob, and he will teach
us of his ways." There's still a
learning period cuz there's people
outside that don't have their glorified
immortal bodies yet. The ones inside are
going to be priests. They're going to be
helping. They're going to be doing these
things. It's going to be unique. Um
they're going to have his law written on
their heart. Like it's fully it's just
amazing um being a part of that first
resurrection. But it says, "And we will
walk in his paths for out of Zion shall
go forth the law." So it's going to be a
glorious time. No war according to
Isaiah. And it says, "Nor shall they at
all be able to destroy any on my holy
mountain." And so they're going to be
protected on his holy mountain, and his
rest shall be glorious rest. Thousand
years, seventh millennial day, talking
about that rest. And so lots of stuff
happening. When you look back in time
from the time that they are saying that
this stuff happened, 70 AD, we have
creeds being written. We have
inquisitions enforcing those creeds for
well over a thousand years. We have so
many things going on that would not be
going on if the Most High was here. He
would not having the Roman Catholic
Church writing creeds to tell us who
Jesus is. Like he would be here. We
could literally go there. People outside
the camp could go there. You don't need
to then hide the Bible, burn people that
have Bibles. Like all the things that
have been going on would not be
happening during the millennial reign.
So this would be a really really long
season and we are in a really really
long season with the same goal as the
little season. And so so many things
have happened, wars after wars,
territories growing, resets happening.
Tartaria was a kingdom. It did get
really big. It did have a lot of
technology, but it wasn't named after
some sort of millennial kingdom people.
You know, I believe that I believe, you
know, evolution, which is Satan's
doctrine, teaches that we are evolving,
that we are getting better. But the
Bible says that Adam and Eve were like
geniuses. Like, I'm sure they used 100%
of their brain. If if any of that
stuff's true, like how do we know we
only use a certain percent of our brain?
I believe that Adam and Eve were
literally geniuses. And oh yeah, Moses
and Noah and all those guys. And we have
gotten dumber. I mean, clearly you can
you can look at um a third grade reading
level like 200 years ago and we can't
even read it. I mean, it's crazy. Yeah.
They kept up with their genealogies for
many hundreds, not thousands of years.
And I don't even know who my great
great-grandfather was. You know what I
mean? It's like they kept track of
things and wrote things down and were
very masterful at doing it and surviving
in ways that we can't even now, you
know. Yeah. And so they have that
millennial kingdom for those who don't
know about the location set up at the
North Pole. Some of them do. I'm not
saying they all believe that, but that's
the common thread that I hear. It's
somewhere at the North Pole. And that's
where the whole Santa Claus uh idea came
from to So now Yeah, they're telling us
Santa's there, but that's where the
actual kingdom is. They say, and you'll
see this right here. Here's a verse from
Jubilees. And there came forth on the
writings as Shim's lot, the middle of
the earth. And so when they're saying
that, Shim was not at the North Pole.
Shim was getting the middle of the dry
land. And when you look at the
continents, the middle of them would be
the middle of the earth, the middle of
the dry land. Whatever continent you're
on, if you're on a small island, the
middle of that continent is the middle
of the earth that you're standing on.
When you pick up Earth in your hand,
it's just dry land. You can hold Earth
in your hand. It's going to have a
middle point. And so saying the center
of the earth or the middle of the earth,
it's not the north pole. And so that
would be the center of the world, if it
even is the center of the world. Our
maps are so flawed now, it's hard to
tell what's what. And so that's just
something to understand. And if you look
at where uh Shem was, that's right there
towards the center of this. If there was
less or I guess less water, more land
back then, this would be a huge massive
chunk of land with um them being right
there in the center of it. And so
precursors, this is going to go fast.
precursors for the millennial reign. So
many things the Messiah talked about the
mark of the beast, false Christ, the sun
being darkened, tribulation, the gospel
of the kingdom being preached in all the
entire world. Lots of these things
happening. This is coming straight out
of the Messiah. I think some people
would argue that those things have
happened though. Yeah. And a lot of
these have we've had false Christ. We've
had the gospel has. And that's the
thing. If you're the enemy and you know
your clock is ticking based on that
gospel message reaching the ends of the
earth, what are you going to do? You're
going to change and muddy the waters and
change that gospel message. And so now
you can have the false preachers going
to evangelizing, going to these places
and you can sit back and relax because
they're teaching your lies, you know.
And so that that's what they're doing.
They've they've had their version of the
gospel spreading far and wide and people
are like, "Woohoo! We're winning." And
they don't realize they're teaching a
corrupted Roman
Romanized version of the gospel. It's
watered down. It's not It's more of a
majority of churches. I mean, the
Catholic Church is the world's largest
Christian quote unquote Christian
denomination. And then every other
mainstream denomination is literally
just a watered down version of Roman
Catholicism. I mean, they're still
clinging to certain aspects. One big
one, Sunday sacredness. Yeah. And they
don't even know it. And and you have and
the ones that are like just made fun of
and stigmatized usually have some
aspects of truth that the others are
missing. And if they would look at them
and go, "Man, what do they have that we
don't?" and study it out, they'd find
out. Yeah. You know, like the Adventists
have some some major truth. The
Jehovah's Witnesses have some major
truth. The Baptists have some truth.
They all like prophecies talking about
them coming together. And my wife said
something brilliant the other day
because you remember um the Jews, the um
the ones that Jesus was dealing with,
the Pharisees and those types, a lot of
people mistake them for being the
father's people that were keeping his
law, but they were keeping the
traditions of men. They were adding to
the word, right? Well, now you have
Christianity taking away from the word.
And she said, you have two groups. Some
that are adding to the word and those
that are taking away. And they both need
to come together and you know what I
mean? fix like and and that's what the
prophecies tell us that they're those
two sticks are going to come together um
the Jews and Israel because the Jews
aren't is all Israel they're a part of
Israel and they're just a couple of the
tribes they're not all of them so when
you hear Jews people think Israel but
there's a difference and so there's pro
neither Jew nor Greek were all one in
Christ Jesus were all Abraham's seed and
heirs according to the promise and
everybody wants to believe that part but
they don't for some reason they still
put a lot of focus on Jews are God's
chosen people and anti-semitism and I
stand with Israel and all that stuff.
Man, there is no such thing. It's we're
all one, but you got to believe in
Christ and the Jews don't. Yeah. Read
Isaiah 56. You know, like it tells you
there are even some that are bloodborne
that aren't his. You know, they're
there's people that are going to do the
things that please him and be grafted in
essentially. Pretty cool stuff. And so,
right here, just real quick precursors.
This is going to be a fast rundown. Um,
you have the Messiah talking about the
abomination of desolation. Um, after the
king, after the gospel message has been
preached to all the world, he's going to
set himself up according to Daniel the
prophet. He's telling them about that.
Hey, remember Daniel the prophet saying
this? It's going to happen. And he says,
"Who so read, let him understand, then
let them which be in Judah flee into the
mountains. Let him which is on the
housetop not come down to take anything
out of his house, neither let him which
is in the field return back to his
clothes. And woe to them that are with
child, and to them that give suck in
those days. But pray ye that your
flight, it's interesting talking about
flights. I didn't know they had flights
back then. Um, be not in the winter,
neither on the Sabbath day. As in
anyway, as in like there's still a
Sabbath day after the resurrection.
Imagine that.
Talking about these things false. Yeah,
that's a good before. I love that verse
just because I've heard so many people
including Ray Comfort and stuff say that
Jesus never said anything about the
Sabbath. I literally have a video of Ray
Comfort saying Jesus never he spoke on
every commandment and never said
anything about the Sabbath. I was like
really pray that your flight not be on
the Sabbath day. Anyway, I don't know
why people get on that Sunday meant
Sunday. He knew Rome would fix it.
That's right.
He knew them popes would come along and
set us all straight. Give us Easter. So
now we can paint some eggs on the
sacrifice of all time painted eggs. That
video is coming out tomorrow, by the
way. Yeah, that's interesting because
Yeah, we have the the painted egg stuff
that yours is going to be far deeper
because it goes deep. Yeah. And I was
listen I was remembering what that that
video you exposed about that guy who's
deceived by the demonic alien talking
about something big's gonna happen this
year on Easter with a and
I'm like oh did he say 2026? Yeah, it's
next year. Well, okay. The the lady the
lady Hathor who he believes is the Holy
Spirit literally has told him her name
is Hatherhor, which is a Egyptian
goddess who comes out of the egg. But he
believes it's the Holy Spirit, which
this this is all just this is what
Satan's doing. He's creating a one world
religion where he can say, "Yeah, yeah,
they they interpret it as Hatheror. We
know it as a Holy Spirit and you know it
is something else, but it's all the same
thing." But he said she comes every
Easter. It's a very special day is what
he said. But he said that she told him
last time that there was something very
significant going to happen 2026 on
Easter. And he said for the first time,
he said, "I've never said this before,
but he said it on on the air on this
video that got millions of views." He
said, "I believe it's the second
coming." So it's like be ready for a
false messiah to come in 2026. I thought
that was this year. So I'm I'm glad I
know. Now I know we got another year,
bro. Year, people. Enjoy it. Just
kidding. Get ready. Be prepared because
he we've got warnings that we that are
we're right there. I feel I believe with
the false the fake comes first. I had a
man tell me that the fake comes first.
His name is Dennis and he says that and
it's like so true. The fake comes first.
And the Messiah is telling him that
they're going to show all these great
signs and wonders. And remember they
were doing that in Egypt. They were
trying to mimic what the Most High was
doing. They could never undo what the
father had done. And they gave up after
a few plagues. They they made it to the
boils and they're like we're done, you
know, but they never could undo what the
father did, you know,
never. And so, um, lots of things here.
It says immediately after the
tribulation of those days shall the sun
be darkened and the moon shall not give
her light, and the stars shall fall from
heaven. They're still there. And the
powers of the heaven shall be shaken,
and then shall appear the sign of the
son of man in heaven. And then shall all
the tribes of the earth mourn. And they
shall see the son of man coming in the
clouds of heaven. Every eye is going to
see this. With power and great glory,
and he shall send his angels with a
great sound of a trumpet, and they shall
gather together his elect from the four
winds. And you know what's cool about
the four winds? Scientists didn't
discover the four jet streams until the
1920s. I never heard of it.
The four winds are there. There's four
jet streams that circle above us at
about 5 to 10 miles talking about this
way back when and they're mentioned by
other prophets too. So his prophets know
creation and so he's talking about them
and now they're an everyday part of life
because planes flying go and experience
those four winds every single time they
fly. Wow. And so really really cool and
the Messiah talking about that and he
says from one end of heaven to the other
and he says now learn a parable of the
fig tree which his branch is yet tender
and putteth forth leaves you know that
summer is nigh. And if you've never had
a fig tree just know that if you do have
one you'll think that it's dead for a
long time because everything's budding
and blooming except for your fig tree.
It's the last one to bloom the one on
our property. And I always I was
praying. I'm like please let it come
back. And I it would it would come back
and I'm like it's a miracle. And in
reality, I didn't know fig trees just
take longer. And so, uh, he's they knew
these things. They were farmers. They
knew fig trees bloom later. And so, he
says, "Ye know that summer is nigh. So
likewise, ye when you shall see all
these things, know that it is near, even
at the doors, verily I say unto you,
this," and he says, "This generation
shall not pass." And they go, "See
there." He's talking about your
generation. Now, he didn't say your
generation shall not pass. He says,
"This generation." He's talking about
the generation that's experiencing all
these things. the fig tree generation.
And he says, "And all these things be
fulfilled." They have to. And he says,
"Heaven and earth shall pass away, but
my word shall not pass away, but of the
day and hour knoweth no man, no, not the
angels of heaven, but my father only."
And so, lots of precursors there in
Matthew. You can see them right here.
You can take a screenshot of that. All
these things pointed out that the stars
are still there. Like, as you're going
through, it's awesome that you're
saying, "Okay, this didn't happen. We
still have stars." I I want to know
where are all the resurrected people. I
mean, yeah, they're still there with the
saints. They have to be because they
don't leave. They they have to be there.
So, when Christ returns, it says the
dead in Christ arise first. The uh those
who are alive and remain will meet him
in the air. And yeah, the wicked will be
consumed by the brightness of his
coming. There's nobody left in the way I
understand it. Yeah. Yeah. some and and
I I'll go through that because that's a
big one for me. Um because we're going
to meet them in the air and then they're
gathering and there will be the wicked.
There's going to be a lot knocked out,
but there's going to be survivors, the
ones that aren't wicked, but they're not
resurrected saints. They're they're
there surviving. That's why they're
camping or that's how they're able to go
and attack the camp of the saints
because they've been on a path for
righteousness. There's a um there's
prophecies about it and we'll get into
that. And so there's the
precursors. And of course, chapter 8 of
Revelation has another one here. The uh
that there fell a great star from heaven
burning as it were a lamp and it fell
upon the third part of the rivers and
upon the fountains of the waters. And
the name of the star is called wormwood.
And right here it says, "There was a
great earthquake and the sun became
black as sackloth in Revelation of hair
and the moon became as blood and the
stars of heaven fell." So, Revelation
talking about that again confirming what
the Messiah already said.
And here we're getting to the prophet.
This is a big one. Go ahead. Oh man, my
camera. Hold on. Let me press a button
here real
quick. It's dying. Low battery.
And I'll be glad to look at questions
later. I'm just trying to go through
this as
fast as we can without losing people
because I know I'm I go too fast
sometimes. Technical difficulties. So I
I see some people in here. I want to
address something. I'm not sure if
you're going
to. They said uh where is it at? It
said Jesus said some some standing here
won't taste death before the Son of Man
comes with power.
Interest. Yeah. Yeah. We'll talk about
that one. That one's one that I'll get
to here in just a little bit. So stay
tuned. You don't want to miss that one.
That's a big one. You're not going to
taste death and until this event
happens. He was talking about when he
was entering in and going into his
father's kingdom. And Judas, I mean, he
could have just said, "All right, Judas,
you're going to betray me. You're going
to be dead. Some of you standing here
are not going to die until you see this,
right?" Yeah. After you resurrect,
you're not going to
die. Some of the people are going to see
this event and they're not going to die
until they've seen it. So once they've
seen it, then they go and they do their
gospel thing, sending the message
around, persecution, and they die. You
You are going to get to that or are we
discussing it now? Yeah, I'll get to
that. Yeah, it it'll it'll be so clear
hopefully because to me that's one
that's a big one and that is I'm glad
you brought that up because that's where
a lot of confusion comes and I had to
address a lot of this stuff individually
verse by verse because yeah after the
resurrection guys you're not going to
taste death. These people were going to
taste death after they saw the the um
the beloved son entering into his
father's kingdom not returning with it
and returning and setting up the
kingdom. So they did, they watched him.
You can read about it. They were
watching him as he went into his
father's kingdom. And so here's events
according to the prophets um before the
millennial reign, I believe. And if I'm
ever wrong by on any of these, let me
know. But Joel chapter 3 talks about
that again. The sun, oh, look at that.
Sounds like the Messiah was using the
same spirit of prophecy here. The sun
and the moon shall be darkened and the
stars shall withdraw their shining. It's
a little different wording. You can look
at different translations and see what
that means. The Lord also shall roar out
of Zion and utter his voice from
Jerusalem and the heavens and the earth
shall shake. So there's the earthquake
and the stars again. And then here Egypt
will be desolate according to Joel.
People still there a day of darkness and
glooiness, a day of cloud and thick
darkness and Zephaniah. He shall destroy
the sinners thereof out of it. People,
yeah, we still got sinners right right
about now. people from every nation,
this is a big one, according to Isaiah
and Zechariah, required to go to the
kingdom to celebrate the feast of
tabernacles and worship Yahweh so they
re can receive rain. I don't know
anybody in my family history any year
ever has gone there to do that out of
this nation. And you know, maybe we have
people sneakily going from every nation,
but why would they be sneaky? They would
be doing this. I mean, they're they have
to to get rain, and no one's doing it.
Still getting rain. I thought you read a
verse, but you didn't. Let me see if I
can find it real quick. Um there's a
verse that says there'll be no more for
one there's no more sea. We have seas
everywhere. For another there's no more
light no more need for the light of the
sun or the moon or something. Yeah. No
more wars. Like so many things. It's
going to be a grand time that thousand
years while the enem is bound and
there's no people getting deceived.
They're going to be on the path for
righteousness things. You're not going
to be paying taxes on food. the world,
it's going to grow out of the earth. And
there's some in Revelation, there's some
prophecies that are really going to
bring it in that we're definitely not
there yet. Um, but it has to do with the
leaves of the tree of life. The tree of
life has been preserved. It's going to
make a comeback and the leaves, it says,
are going to be healing for the nations.
And so, just the leaves of the tree of
life, imagine making, you know, having
just the leaves um from the tree of
life. People are going to be living for
a long time. And the fourth book of Ezra
says that if somebody dies at a hundred
years, you're going to think they're
tragically young babies. You know, like
people are going to be living kind of
like they were back with Adam and Eve.
Like they're going to live a long time.
So that's how um that's how all these
celebrities are doing. Kiana Reeves and
stuff, right?
That's how they look so young. Like
that's the millennial reigns going on.
They're getting those leaves. That that
is a good point. Like I've never seen
anybody use use that, but they could.
You know those time traveler pictures
like Kiana Reeves back in the medieval
days and stuff? He kept them. He kept
some of them leaves and he just hijacked
them. And so this one right here, this
is Zechariah. This is a big one. It says
Yahweh shall be king over all the earth.
In that day there shall be one Yahw and
his name one. And that's why when you
read about Gog and Magog and the end of
the little season, what's happening?
They're deceiving the nations. They're
no longer deceiving the kings. They're
just deceiving nations because there are
no kings. And he says here in uh
Zechariah again, I will gather you from
the four winds. Oh, look at that. Four
winds of heaven before the Messiah said
it. And they there shall be no more
utter destruction, but Jerusalem shall
be safely inhabited. Not happening. Then
will I turn the people to a pure
language, undoing the Tower of Babel.
Has that happened? Let me call my
friends in China. That hasn't happened.
Yeah. that they may call upon the name
of Yahweh. So they're all it's going to
be restored. We're going to have
restoration. We're going to have our
languages converted to a pure language.
All other kingdoms will end. That's
going to happen. No more kingdoms. No
more kings. Everyone shall worship
Yahweh from their location. That's
sometimes happening. I mean, people are
worshiping around the world, but not to
that degree. Well, I think some of the
confusion here though is that we are
beyond the thousand years. Now we're
living under Satan's deception.
But yeah, but we've never seen
Yeah. We've never seen any history of
any of this stuff happening.
Yeah. Teaching the people to now have
kings and then have languages and like
it's the goal is simple. Get them to
attack that camp. That is it. You know,
like with the little season and so right
here, world worldwide resurrection first
Corinthians and gathering of the elect.
The elect will meet Yahweh and Yeshua in
the air. First Thessalonians, two
witnesses killed,
and all that dwell upon the earth shall
worship him, the beast whose name are
not written in the book of life of the
lamb. That had to have happened already
back then, 70
AD. And then it says here in Revelation,
let's see where I'm at right now.
Revelation 16, the Euphrates will dry
up. That's actually happening right now.
It's precursor. It's That's true.
Merchants of the earth deceive the whole
world with pharmarmacia. Seems like that
just happened. Yeah. And then um right
here it says in the midst of the street
of it and on either side, this is a big
one. Either side of the river was there
the tree of life. This is during the
millennial reign. Which bear 12 manner
of fruits. Think about that. 12 months
in the year. You probably get a new
fruit each month. And yielded her fruit
every month. What? Think about that.
Every month it's yielding fruit. It's
not one. There's not just one season.
Every month it's yielding fruit. And the
leaves of the tree were for the healing
of the nations. the healing, the ones
that survived Armageddon. He's going to
mark his own people for protection. If
you're meant to survive, those
hellstones can't touch you. When his
people were in Egypt and those
hellstones were falling, right? His
people didn't get hit. When the plagues
were happening, there wasn't a single
one of their people hurt by these
plagues. They were protected. When Egypt
was in darkness, his people had light.
Our father distinguishes between his
people. And so, the survivors are going
to have healing from those leaves of the
tree of life. And that tree of life is
spectacular. Enoch sees it and smells
it. And he says the smell got into his
bones. And I thought that's weird. What
does that mean? Well, guess what? Guess
where your blood comes from? Your blood
comes from your bones. Wow. He's talking
about aroma so powerful that you smell
it. It gets into your bones. It's a tree
of life. The life is in the blood. This
thing that needed to be protected. He
didn't, you know, whenever Adam and Eve
and they sinned, he was guarding the
tree of life. That's what he guarded
with those cherubams. And so, it's
making a comeback. It's been protected,
elevated. And right here, there's that
verse, tree of life, 12 fruits, yielding
them every month. I would say one new
fruit per month, but I could be wrong.
It may have a variety every single
month, but it's going to be spectacular.
That's not set up on the earth right now
anywhere. If it was, I'm going there.
I'm breaking whatever tree I have to
break. I'm going there to get some of
them leaves. Even just the leaves,
that's what I want. And so, we're seeing
a lot of these precursors happening now.
Um, locations. According to prophecy, it
doesn't talk about the North Pole in
Ezekiel. He talks about, it says here,
"They shall dwell in their land which I
have given to my servant Jacob." And you
can do history on that. See where he
gave that land to him. And it says,
"Where their fathers dwelt, and they
shall dwell upon it, and David my
servant, prince forever. And I will make
with them a covenant of peace. It shall
be an everlasting covenant with them.
And I will establish my sanctuary in the
midst of them forever. and my tabernacle
shall be among them. And I will be to
them a God, and they shall be my people,
and the nations, not the kings anymore,
the nations shall know that I am the
Lord that sanctifies them when my
sanctuary is in the midst of them
forever. It's not leaving. It's not
going to go hide, staying there forever.
And right here, here's another location,
Mount of Olives. This is where the
Messiah was setting when he was talking
about end time events. He was sitting on
the Mount of Olives. He knew where this
was going to happen. Yeah. And he's
talking to his disciples about the Mount
of Olives. And we're talked about as
being grafted in. This is what I find
very powerful. Grafted into the olive
tree, right? Isn't that what they use to
talk about spiritual Israel? And guess
what? If you're grafting something in,
do you does it require a professional
gardener to do or can you just leave
your plants outside and they'll graft
into each other? Grafting requires a
professional gardener, somebody to do
it. It's not a natural process. But the
olive tree and any tree when you're
grafting in has to be of a similar kind.
Olive trees are one of two trees out of
all the trees in existence, you know,
about 73,000 trees that has 46
chromosomes. You and I have 46
chromosomes. And so we're being grafted
into the olive tree. Chromosomes weren't
discovered until the 1800s, allegedly.
And so our father knew when he was
telling his prophets to use this tree
how many chromosomes it had. He knew how
many chromosomes we had.
And so the Messiah talking about the
return happening on the Mount of Olives,
which has that olive connection there.
And guess where? He's harvesting his
olives. You know, those fruits and all
those people. He's going to come down.
Actually, this is actually not um where
they come down. They have the
resurrection. We're gathered up. We know
we're going to be close to this mount of
olives because it says here in Zechariah
this time of war when they're trying to
war against the most high it says and
his feet shall stand in that day upon
the mount of olives which is before
Jerusalem on the east and the mount of
olives shall
cleave in the midst thereof towards the
east and towards the west and there
shall be a very great valley and half of
the mountain shall remove towards the
north and the other half towards the
south. Dude, that's amazing. I mean,
just imagine they're trying to war
against the most high. This mountain is
not going to stand a chance when his
feet touch down. Boom. Like, but that
mountain is together. It's not split.
So, that's like nail in the coffin right
there. Like, super amazing verse unless
we got technology to push the mountain
back together. Yeah, we'd put it back
together. He'd let us in that time. So,
I just I don't I don't think so. I don't
think that we would be able to to do all
that in a little short season. Like,
that would be overkill. And so,
right here is talking about what Jesus
said. He says, "And as he said on the
Mount of Olives, the disciples came unto
him privately, saying, tell us when all
these things shall be and what shall be
the sign of thy coming and the end of
the world." So that's where they were. I
find that fascinating. And um here's
more locations. It says here that the
land shall be in Zachchariah. The land
shall be turned as a plain from Gibba to
Rimman south of Jerusalem, and it shall
be lifted up and inhabited in her place,
from Benjamin's gate unto the place of
the first gate unto the corner gate, and
from the tower of Hanil unto the king's
wine presses. So, you're getting actual
geographic locations. It's not hiding.
It's not telling us that it's just a
temporary location. It's going to move.
It's being set up forever. The king of
Israel, even the Lord, is in the midst
of thee, Zephaniah. So shall ye know.
And here's Joel. Joel's a prophet that I
am the Lord your God dwelling in Zion,
my holy mountain. And in that time shall
the presence be brought to the Lord of
hosts from a people afflicted and impeed
and from a people great from henceforth
and forever a nation hoping and trotten
down which is in a part of a river of
his land to the place where is the name
of the Lord of hosts, the Mount Zion. So
where he's choosing to set his name,
that's a big deal. Don't take his name
in vain. He's choosing to put his name
there to my holy mountain. It says here
in Isaiah in
Jerusalem, sayeth the Lord. Lots of
locations. Let me see if I can find some
more verses here. I think I'm getting to
the end of this presentation.
So, I'm just kind of pointing out some
of these places on maps. Dude, you need
like a bullet point list at the end to
wrap it up to be like the stars are
still above us. The sea is still here.
The mountain is not split.
I mean, yeah, the center of the earth
right there, center of the dry land. And
so, lots of things. And um this talks
about the evil one here. How art thou
fallen from heaven, oh Lucifer, son of
the morning? How art thou cut down to
the ground which did weaken the nations?
From thou hast said in thine heart, I
will ascend into heaven. I will exalt my
throne above the stars of God. I will
sit also upon the mount of the
congregation. The appointed times is
what that means. That's a weird word to
mean appointed times, but look up the
original word. I will set upon the mount
of the appointed times in the sides of
the north. Sounds like there's someone
wanting to set up in the
north. And now we're saying that that's
where the kingdom
is. Very, very
interesting. Isaiah Septuagent says, "On
the lofty mountains toward the north, I
will go above the clouds. I will be like
the most high." And now we we all every
year Santa Claus, he's up north, you
know. Yep,
that's where he's at. And then Zachariah
says, "Ho ho." Listen to this. Remember
who says ho ho. Santa Claus, right?
Santa Claus says ho ho and green. This
isn't Santa Claus. This says ho ho. Free
from the land of the north, saith the
Lord.
So now we got Santa Claus saying ho ho.
No, he's saying flee from north. No. And
they're saying, "Oh, go to the North
Pole." That's where Santa is. The Most
High says, "Ho ho, flee from the land of
the north, sayeth the Lord. I will
gather you from the four winds of
heaven.
Think about that. Four winds. So you're
seeing the four winds connection. This
isn't just the Messiah talking randomly.
Prophets are saying it flee from the
land of the north. But now we're wanting
to go there and see if the kingdom's
there. It's not there. He's telling them
to flee from it. So I I mean this stuff
is so widespread in Christianity that we
we take to customs and you know Most
High is talking about through his
prophets. Lots of stuff. So much in
here. here. I mean, I'm telling you,
hundreds of slides.
Um, Zephaniah, the remnant of Israel,
shall not do iniquity, nor speak lies,
neither shall a deceitful tongue be
found in their mouth, for they shall
feed and lie down, and none shall make
them afraid. Right now, people are in
fear. Of course, they say, I guess it's
the little season. Yeah, that's what
they're trying to do. Get us in fear.
Not doing
iniquity for a thousand years. I don't
know if that's ever happened for a
thousand years.
See? And so, man, um, and then the
yellow here, Yahweh, their God, their
Yahw, in the midst of thee is mighty. He
will save. He will rejoice over thee
with joy. He will rest in his love. He
will joy over thee with singing.
Hallelujah. That's powerful. I get
emotional thinking about this because
this is going to happen. He's going to
be joying over you with singing. You are
his inheritance. He has an inheritance.
What is it? We're waiting for streets of
gold and all these fancy things. He's
waiting to inherit his people. Tells us
throughout the word that's his
inheritance. And he is joying over them
with singing. Be humble and know the
creator of heaven and earth wants you as
his inheritance. It's powerful. And he
says, I will gather them that are
sorrowful for the solemn assembly who
are of thee to whom the reproach of it
was a burden. Behold, at that time I
will undo all that afflict thee, and I
will save her that halth, and gather her
that was driven out. And I will get them
praise and fame in every land where they
have been put to shame. So all the shame
you're going through for spreading
truth, all the things you're doing, the
persecution, he's going to make it
right. He's going to joy over you.
Powerful. Zephaniah chapter 3, read
these prophets because Peter tells us to
be mindful of them. But here's what they
were saying in the New Testament while
they're trying to spread the gospel.
This is in 2 Timothy chapter 2. It says,
"Keep away from godless babbling for
those who engage in it will only become
more ungodly. And their teaching will
eat away at people like Gang Green,
Himaeus, they're naming people here, and
Felus are among these. They have missed
the mark as far as truth is concerned by
saying that our resurrection has already
taken place." Wow. And they are
overturning some people's faith.
So back then saying, "Hey, these people
are overturning people's faith." And
I've had people comment and say, "Man,
I've been looking into this and it's
starting to look true that we're in the
little season and it's shaking my
faith." They use those words, "It's
shaking my faith. I don't know what to
believe." And it's a scary place because
it's like, "Oh my goodness, we're we're
not awaiting the resurrection. We are
after the little season and they've
hidden everything." And I get that. They
lie. Yes, we are. And they say, "He's
deceiving the whole nations." Because
when you read that wording, that's what
it sounds like. They're deceiving the
nations right now. Yes, they are. That's
happening in the long season and in the
little season. They're both the same
purpose. To get you together to battle
the Most High and his saints both times,
same thing. And so, keep away from that
godless babbling. It says back then, and
I I mean, I wish they would have just
been like, they knew we're going to be
reading this. They weren't like just
this generation, you know, 20 years from
now. Believe him, you know, because he
says the Messiah says if they say I'm in
the desert, don't believe it. That's
right. If they say I'm in the North
Pole, I he might as well. If they say
that, don't believe it. It's going to be
like lightning. Every eye is going to
see. And so, right now, we're being told
he's here. He's somewhere else.
Resurrection's already happened. And so,
they were dealing with that back then.
It's amazing. And yeah, powerful stuff.
And this is second
Thessalonians. Read. Let me see what
this one is. Even him who Satan's. Um,
remember ye not that when I was with
you, I told you these things. And now
you know what withholdeth that he might
be revealed in his time. For the mystery
of iniquity, that word iniquity means
lawlessness does already work. What are
they trying to get us to do now? Trying
to be lawless. Yeah, that work. Forget
about the law. That stuff's been
abolished, destroyed. You don't need
that. That's old stuff. And so only he
who now letth, and this is worded really
weird. If you look up in the complete
Jewish Bible, the what this says, it
makes a lot more sense. Only he who now
letth will let. I'm like, what does that
mean? Um, until he was taken out of the
way and then shall the wicked be
revealed. And and basically, you had
them working to push away the law. And
they were changing the Sabbath. They
were changing they were making up new
appointed times. They were doing
everything they could to get people into
lawlessness. And people didn't know it.
Then now we don't even know what
lawlessness looks like because we grew
up in it. And so uh it says here once
that wicked one be revealed which is
going to happen whom the Lord shall
consume with the spirit of his mouth and
shall destroy with the brightness of his
coming even him whose coming is after
the working of Satan with all powers and
signs and lying wonders. So we're
getting ready for those lying wonders.
They're going to happen. We're going to
see them. It's going to look real. Yeah.
So many good that was a good verse. um
because it says that he's going to
destroy that it it's all in the context
of his second coming and it says that
he's going to consume the wicked with
the brightness of his coming. So I don't
understand how anyone could be here
right now if Christ returned, the
righteous, dead and alive were taken up
to meet him in the air and the wicked
were consumed by the brightness of his
coming.
Um, there should not be anyone here
right now if that's the case. Yeah. Did
you get to the end of your slides?
I'm trying to see where I'm at. I know
I've got I always have a bunch of extra
slides tucked away at the end. I want to
make sure
some of the stuff comments coming in.
Um, yeah. And I want to address some of
the scriptures because I know that was a
big one. I want to get to that before
you got them up. I run out of time. Let
me share that
location scriptures with context. Let me
full screen
that.
Um, yeah, somebody in here said that the
northern lights are emitting from
Christ's throne.
Yeah, I get and there's aspects with the
firmament that are electrical, powerful,
and I don't doubt it has something to do
with what's above the firmament, but
right, we'll get into that because this
is the common a lot. Jesus said this
generation I get yelled at like
literally like that. Um and how like we
said earlier, how can that man hand be
2,000 years? Well, John was saying that
John the Baptist saying kingdom of
heaven is at hand. Means it's definitely
very close. It's right at hand. Very
very close. Jesus was telling them in
Matthew chapter 10 as you go preach
saying the kingdom of heaven is at hand.
Why would he be telling them to lie to
people? Right? That time Jesus began to
preach and say repent for the kingdom of
heaven is at hand. Well, let's go back
and look at what was being said 740
years earlier. This is from Isaiah. 740
BC somewhere around there. How ye, for
the day of the Lord is at hand. It shall
come as a destruction from the Almighty.
Wow. BC. The day is near. Even the day
of the Lord is near. The cloudy day it
shall be. The time of the heathen. Dude,
these are good.
Here's 640 BC again. Somewhere around
there. Zephaniah, for the day of the
Lord is at
hand. Joel, day of the Lord is at hand.
Day of the Lord cometh, for it is nigh
at
hand. Over and over and over, you see
the same thing. The Messiah keeping up
and speaking what his father told him to
say. And it's the same types of things
he was telling his prophets to say to
get people ready. It's always at hand.
You and I aren't going to live very
long. Our little short lives, it's at
hand to us. If I live to be a hundred,
it's at hand to me. It's right there.
It's I can only go to my lifespan. This
is a short little trial we're in. And so
to everybody that's ever lived, it's
always been right at hand for everyone.
And so it is at hand. It's near. And his
kingdom, there's actually spiritual
aspects to it as well. He talks about
the kingdom being within, you know, and
so he's telling us to pray, "Thy kingdom
come." Not thy kingdom already came.
It's going to come. that keep is going
to come. And so here's one right here.
He's talking to his disciples. This is
the one um that gets really really out
of context. So pay close attention. This
is chapter 10. This is one of their
powerful verses. It says right here,
"But when they persecute you in this
city, flee ye into another. For verily I
say unto you, ye shall not have gone
over the cities of Israel till the Son
of Man be come." Oh my goodness. Look at
that right there. He said they're not
even going to finish going over Israel,
right? And then the son of man's going
to come back. But wait a minute, didn't
he say it's going to reach the entire
world? Yeah. Before he comes back. So,
how's it going to reach the entire world
before he comes back? But it doesn't
even reach Israel. And so, you have to
understand this specific quote. He's
giving them instructions to go and teach
people and they're going to meet up
again. And so he's talking about them
meeting back up. And what happened
later? They met back up.
And so you don't have a contradiction
right here. The gospel of the kingdom
shall be preached in all the
world. Then the end's going to come. And
so he's not contradicting himself. They
end up meeting back
up. He's telling them what to do. When
you look at the context here, it says
these 12 Jesus sent forth and commanded
them, saying, "Go into the way or go not
into the way of the Gentiles and into
any city of the Samaritans, enter you
not, but go rather to the lost sheep of
the house of Israel." And as you go,
preach, saying, "The kingdom of heaven
is at hand." And so, he's telling them,
here's what you're going to do. You're
going to heal the sick, the lepers,
raise the dead, cast out demons. Freely
you have received, freely give, provide
neither gold nor silver. Most of you
guys know this verse. And so he's giving
them instructions and he's saying,
"You're not going to finish going over
all of Israel before I come back and
before they unite." And so right there
it says, "It came to pass that when
Jesus had made an end of commanding his
12 disciples, he departed thence to
teach and to preach in their city." And
so he's departing. They're separating.
They didn't have cell phones. They're
going to be gathered back together,
spiritually led back together. And so
what happens is it says at that time
Jesus went on the Sabbath day through
the corn and his disciples were hungry
probably because people weren't taking
them in and feeding them like they
should have. They're out there teaching
basically homeless with the way they're
going out. They're only accepting what's
given to them. They're not acquiring
great wealth. You know, they're doing
this humbly. And so they were hungry.
Sound that gives you some clues as to
how they were treated. And so he did
come back before they finished going
over all of Israel. He didn't have a
whole lot of time here once he started
his
ministry. And so he says here in chapter
16, "Verily I say unto you, there be
some standing here which shall not taste
death till shall not taste death till
they see the son of man coming in his
kingdom." And so that word coming when
you look at it in its translation means
to go. It can mean to go as well. Going
into or entering into his kingdom.
Coming in his kingdom. It's worded very
weirdly in um the King James version.
And so you have to look at the
interlinear. What do those words mean?
Let me see if I have that here. There it
is. Some of you, where's that word? I
thought I circled it. Coming. But you
click on that word. There it is. Coming.
Go. It also means go. I come or I go.
And so you have the son of man going in
his kingdom. And that's what they
witnessed him do in Acts 1:9. when they
had spoken these things while they
beheld, he was taken up and a cloud
received him out of their sight. And so
Judas, what happened to Judas? He was
one of the people there that died before
this event. And so he says, "There be
some standing here." He's not going to
lie. He is not a false witness. He's he
can't say every one of you standing here
is going to witness this. No, he's
saying some of you. And he knew what was
going to happen. So you're saying that
some of them standing that So he was
talking to the 12, I think. Yeah. And
and he said some of you standing here
will see him ascending into heaven.
Yeah. They're not going to taste death
until they've seen him going into his
kingdom. Okay. And so not returning, not
the all these things happening and in
the world, you know, he's telling them
so many things are going to happen,
people are going to kill you, you know,
like you're going to die. Like he's
telling them these things, too. And so
when you think about this, remember
you're not going to taste death till
this happens. So he didn't say you're
not going to die. You're not going to
die until you've seen this. And so I
want to want to say something about that
verse. Um so I'm looking at it
in let me see I'm going to switch. Do
you see my screen here? Okay. So you
were reading Matthew 16:28, right? Truly
I tell you, some of you standing here
will not taste death before you see the
son of man coming in his kingdom. Coming
in his kingdom, coming in his kingdom.
Coming in his kingdom. Yeah, that sounds
like he's going to his kingdom. Coming
in his kingdom. That that makes a lot of
sense actually. I didn't even think of
it that way because I think another one
of the gospels words it differently and
it says, "Until you see him in all his
glory or something like that." Um, let
me see. Um,
KJV some
standing here not taste
death.
Uh let's see. Matthew 16:28. Really? Is
there not another verse? Okay. Also
found in
Luke. Where's the other ones at? All
these are Matthew. Okay. Let me look at
this Luke one real quick
because yeah, what you're saying makes
perfect sense. I actually thought it
might have been another
incident. So in Luke 9:27 it says, "But
I tell you there are some standing here
who will not taste death until they see
the kingdom of
God." Um, and then Mark 91, what does it
say? It says, Yeah, there we go. So Mark
9:1, I'm going to put it in Bible
Hub. So Mark 9:1
says, "Truly I tell you, some are
standing here who will not taste death
till you see the kingdom of God come
with power. God arrive in great
power." Um, kingdom of God arrive with
power. Kingdom of God having with power.
So King James version I usually use says
till they have seen the kingdom of God
come with power and new King James says
kingdom of God present with power.
So when I'm I try to find every answer
from the word of God. I know you do too.
Yeah. so many people that like you said
they get all upset and they're like
they're just telling you what they
believe and I'm like well these four
verses say this and calm and collected
and that's what the word says and
they're like
um so when I started looking into this
and I heard that verse I was like does
the Bible ever
say like like talk about this the power
or whatever and in second Peter 1:16
because one of the people that Jesus was
talking to among the 12 was Peter and
um this is second Peter. He wrote it and
he said, "For we have not followed
cunningly devised fables. We made known
unto you the power and coming of our
Lord Jesus Christ, but were eyewitnesses
of his
majesty." So, I thought this was a
parallel to that verse, like Jesus
saying, "Some of you won't taste death
until you see me come in my power and
come to my kingdom and all that." And
Peter later when he wrote Peter, which
was after Jesus died, this was after uh
Yeah, but you're right. Either
way, this is referring to him going
going into the clouds because they
witness. Yeah. And it also sounds like
Pentecost in the and Mark sounds like
they're talking about, you know, I
actually thought that this was about the
mount of transfiguration. I'm not sure
why, but that's what I thought actually.
Yeah. things Peter saw. I mean, just
thinking about that that the
transfiguration and all that and the
denying aspect, powerful stuff that he
has seen. And that's what he's telling
us. Be mindful of the prophets. And
that's what you got to go back to the
prophets. It's something we overlook. We
get caught up in the New Testament and
flashy videos and revelation and hearing
words, but go back to the prophets. See
what they're saying. See what it points
to. See the what the father's timeline
is showing us through the prophets. And
it's going to bring a lot of clarity.
And so essentially though with that
verse, once you're resurrected, you're
not going to taste death. And this what
he was telling them is you're not going
to taste death until you've seen this.
Then then you're going to taste death.
So not going to taste it after the
resurrection if you're a part of that
first resurrection. And so another one
here, verily I say unto you, this
generation shall not pass till all these
things be fulfilled. That generation, we
talked about that, the fig tree
generation that see all those things
happening. And so you have to color code
these things. There is an audience he's
talking about. He says, "You and you and
you and you and ye and you." And when
you go through and look at it, you're
like, "He's talking to them." Yeah. And
so highlight those words, the um the um
descriptive pronouns he's using, ye,
him, him, his. It starts changing. I
turned it to green because it's talking
about other people now, not you. It's
not saying you like it is at the very
beginning of this right here in chapter
uh 24:15. It says, "When ye therefore
shall see the abomination of desolation
spoken of by Daniel the prophet, stand
in the holy place. Who so readeth," why
is it saying, "Who so readeth?" You
know, he's talking to these people. Um,
let him
understand. He's knowing people need to
read. They need to read what the prophet
Daniel was talking about. Then let them
which being Judah flee to the mountain.
So, we've already gone over all this,
but keep looking. Keep looking at the um
pronouns, it starts talking about the
elect's sake, you all these different
times. Then when you get to Matthew
24:29, still reading on immediately
after the tribulation of those days,
shall the sun be darkened. It's talking
about those things we've already read
about. Tribes of there shall mourn and
they he's talking to the disciples. Why
didn't he say you? Why didn't he say you
shall see the son of man? He says they
shall see the son of man coming in the
clouds. Good. Very good point. I don't
want anyone to miss that. What you're
saying
is that Yeshua was saying to his
disciples like you, youu and all this,
but when he's talking about these future
things about tribulation like we've
never seen and and we'll never see
again, he's saying they he's not saying
you guys are going to see it because in
70 AD they're still alive. John the
Revelator was writing in 90 AD. Yeah. So
he definitely would have seen this and
he would have said, "Well, actually John
the Revelator, if he wrote that in 90
AD, he would have been writing that
after the second return of Christ."
Yeah. So why was he on the aisle of
Patmos? Why was he a prisoner?
Why was he boiled in a pot of boiling
oil?
What up,
little man showed up? Somebody did y'all
the fam bam.
My blue-eyed wonder here and my
browneyed girl. There they are.
Browneyed.
What's up? Family reunion.
All right, y'all. Go back in there.
Thank you, boy. Thank you, boy. Close
that door back. Dude, this is I I'm glad
we're studying this out because it
really does reveal truth. Like if Christ
returned at 70 AD, then John the
Revelator was sitting there on an island
of Patmos, boiling in oil, writing this
letters
encrypted for who?
Yeah, cuz he's saying he saw the souls
of the dead still waiting for the
resurrection.
Why is he seeing the souls of the dead,
you know, slain? Like why is he seeing
them awaiting a resurrection?
They've already gone. They're already at
the kingdom, you know. Yeah. And the
only the only argument I can hear people
saying is how do you know that it was 90
AD it was you know but either way could
have been still it's still future like
this is happening in the future and
there's still people waiting right if it
was 70 AD or even a couple years before
he's still writing this cryptic message
to people in the
future that makes no sense that have
been slaughtered for trying to teach the
good news and trying to get it to the
rest of the
right? You know, and so these are people
who died doing that. They were burned at
the stake. They were punished and
they're are going, "When is our time
going to come? When are we going to see
them avenged and us, you know,
resurrected, so to speak?" And he's
like, they're given robes and it's like,
"Wait yet a little season." So,
somebody's saying that John said he was
on the aisle of Patmos, meaning it was
past tense. But like we're saying, even
if it was 50 AD, why is he
writing the whole book of Revelation
talking about what's to come, the mark
of the beast and all this stuff?
Yeah. For the people, I guess, that are
right there like in, you know, 10 years
ahead of his time or something. I don't
know. They had to do some rapid Bible
studies and and print this out and
invent the printing press and get this
stuff out like been hard to get this out
to the whole world because the the when
they're doing all these things, the New
Testament didn't exist yet while this is
going on. The New Testament is not
there. They only have the Old Testament.
The gospel has to that message needs to
reach the entire world. It's going to
take some time. I mean, the Holy Spirit
can do some amazing things. Yeah. and
put that spirit to do that. But ravens
are flying with scrolls.
Yeah. So, there's there's a lot of
things. Here's some some some other ones
here. This is the fig tree. Terrible
with the fig tree, but I think we talked
about this one in the last video, so I
don't want to keep covering the same
things. Um they there's the they see the
son of man coming. We just talked about
that. Some of the some of his disciples
were remarking, let's see, what I got
here.
um remarking about how the temple was
adorned with beautiful stones and with
gifts dedicated to God. And it says, "As
for these things which you behold, the
days will come in the which there shall
not be left one stone upon another that
shall not be thrown down." And so that
temple was definitely destroyed. A lot
of the language is talking about that
and that event did happen and that
wasn't the return. It was just the
temple being destroyed. We don't need it
anymore. The Messiah is our high priest.
Amen. We're going to be reigning with
him hopefully being a part of that first
resurrection. It's what you want to do.
Blessed and holy are they that are.
Yeah. And so, lots of different things
here. Again, highlighting the pronouns
when you look through the book of Luke.
I I did it from different books because
it's the same story, but it's told a
little differently from Matthew, Mark,
Luke, and John. And so, you see the same
thing with Luke. It goes from you and
your and ye to them, them, them, them,
they this people. You know, the the
pronouns are changing for a reason. The
Messiah is being honest. He's telling
them people, they these. And um until
the times of the Gentiles be fulfilled,
talking to the they them. Yeah. The they
thems, the they men's men's hearts
felling. They and them. Not you. You got
to notice that there'll be some of
them. This is a big one. Mark 9:1. This
is a powerful one here. And he said unto
them, verily I say unto you, that there
be some of them that stand here, which
shall not taste death till they have
seen the kingdom of God come with power.
So, we were just going over, you went
over this one as well. Um, but it's the
them when I was talking about the
kingdom of God that
time some of them, the adulterous
generation. Mark 9. Look at that. We're
in an adulterous generation. I believe
everybody would agree with sinful.
That's why people think we're in the
little season. They think Satan's
deceiving the world and there's so many
satanic things going on in the world.
And and he is he's deceiving the entire
world. There's unclean spirits at work
now. Yeah. It talks about that time
period. It's just the evil one coming
out. So now we have unclean spirits. We
obviously have demon possession. We
obviously have people like Alistister
Crowley talking to demons, summoning
demons. And so that stuff's going on.
It's a a long season aspect. We're in
the long season. We're getting ready for
first resurrection. The first
description Jesus said when they asked
him what would be the sign of his
coming, he said, "Let no man deceive
you." It was all about deception and
lying signs and wonders and miracle
working demons and all that stuff.
So yeah, of course the world's been
deceived. Adam and Eve were deceived or
Eve was deceived. You know, yeah, it's
nothing new that the world. It's always
been a narrow way. Jesus said, "Broad is
the way that leads to destruction. Only
few will find the way to life." And then
it gets more descriptive. It says, "A
remnant." And um you know, Satan's going
after the remnant and only the elect
will not be deceived. Like it's always
been the majority. The Satan's the god
of this world that's blinding the minds
of unbelievers. Like all the language
says that Satan has been deceiving the
world this whole time. And yeah, and
people will talking about, you know,
Satan being bound, you know, he's going
to be bound for a thousand years, right?
And so here's one right here. Romans 16,
it says, "And the God of peace shall
bruise Satan under your feet shortly."
How does shortly mean 2,000 years? This
is very, you know, and and I get things
like this all the time and I understand.
But think about this. When you're
teaching the good news, you're bruising
him under your feet. You're not binding
him under the ground. You're bruising
him under your feet. So, there's a
difference between bruising under your
feet versus binding him in the ground so
he's not doing any deceiving because
that's going to continue to happen. Your
message is doing damage to his work. His
work is against the Messiah and the
father. Spirit of the antichrist, like
John says in 1 John chapter, I think two
um talks about the spirit of the
antichrist, denying the father and the
son. Everything we're trying to put out
there is doing the opposite of denying.
It's outright proving that there's a
father and a son. It's outright proving
that his creation account is real. And
so their lies are going to go against
it. It's going to deny the father and
the son. They've been doing that since
the creeds, since before the creeds,
since like that's all they've ever done.
And so they've always tried to get them
to worship other gods and deny the
father and the son. And so mainstream
wisdom promoted by the evil ones is
going to get you money, fame, and
wealth. And so that's why you see the
nonsense happening in the world with all
those who deny him or having support of
any teaching that supports the big bang
or denies the creator are going to get
all that worldly wealth thrown at them.
And so, yeah, definitely definitely a
lot to see with these verses. Point
here, somebody said, um, oh man, the
chat's blowing up. I want to see. Yeah,
Paul literally said the gospel was
already preached to every people. Yeah.
So, what do you think about that? I
mean, they turned the world upside down
or whatever, but yeah, has to go to the
ends of the world. And we're not even
allowed right now to travel to the ends
of the world. My brother made a good
point. He goes, you know, um, he's like,
we have that like Antarctic treaty. He's
like, we can't go past the 60th South
parallel. He's like, what if they're
trying to keep the gospel from reaching
some nation that we don't know about
that they made to keep their, you know,
they they have that false sense of like,
oh, we can keep the time from ending by
making a false nation. Kind of like have
them on the Truman Show out here where
they don't realize. Um, that's crazy,
you know. Well, in Japan, I I looked
this up when I was doing the anime
documentary, and it says less than 1% of
Christianity exists in Japan, and they
worship the dragon and all this stuff.
And but what's crazy is so much of anime
that comes out has an inverted Bible
theme in it. Neon Genesis, Seven Deadly
Sins, Death Note. I mean, where are they
getting this? They're they're being
inspired by Satan himself. They don't
even have Christianity out there. Like
people people say, "Well, yeah, you get
a lot of that stuff in America because
we're a Christian nation, all that."
They expect it to be in the art. But
even that's why I know that the same
spirit is deceiving all these
entertainment producers because it's
even happening in a nation where there's
less than 1% of Christianity. They're
still flipping the Bible.
Yeah. Yeah. for sure flipping it all the
time with their programming towards the
youth big time targeting our youth and
um right here I tried to go through like
the guy that sent me the verses the one
guy that sent me like a ton of verses
like thank you so much I tried to go
through every single one of them and and
this was one of them and this was a big
one because it says for this we say unto
you by the word of the Lord that we
which are alive and remain unto the
coming of the Lord shall not prevent
them which are asleep and so they're
like see he's telling people, hey, we're
going to be alive when the return
happens. And remember, Jesus told him,
he said, only my father knows when the
return's going to happen. Like, you're
not going to know the day or the hour.
And so, if they were to claim,
they know when it's going to be. We're
going to be alive. I I always talk about
the return as if I'm going to be alive.
I assume it's going to happen in my
lifetime. I could die. I could be
martyed. I could be wrong. And so, these
people, they ended up being martyed and
dying. The the apostles that wrote
Thessalonians died. Um, I think they
believed Jesus was going to come back in
their lifetime, you know. Oh, yeah. And
for I'm sure they did. And that was how
they they had an urgency, an urgency
that's been lost to that the kingdom is
at hand. We have to have that urgency.
We have to be preaching that. We have to
be teaching thy kingdom come. And now
it's the kingdom already came. Don't
worry about it. And it's it's a
different it does change things. It
doesn't seem like it does, but that's
why Paul was saying it's shaking up
people's faith and those people have
missed the mark where truth is concerned
because they ended up being martyed.
Paul died. He these writers died. The
resurrection didn't happen. John, you
know, to the seven churches, he says,
which are in Asia. Grace be unto you and
peace from him which is and which was
and which is to come. Again, this is 90
AD. Which is to come. Hasn't come yet.
John the
Revelator. And so blessed is he that
readeth and they that hear the words of
this prophecy and keep those things
which are written therein for the time
is at hand. There's that at hand again.
We have to be ready. Fear none of those
things which thou shalt suffer. Behold,
the devil shall cast some of you into
prison that ye may be tried and ye shall
have tribulation 10 days. Be thou
faithful unto death. Not unto that soon
resurrection or the resurrection that
already happened. Unto death. And I will
give thee a crown of
life. And when right here is chapter
six, when he opened the fifth seal, I
saw under the altar the souls of them
that were slain for the word of God and
for the testimony which they held.
Because at n in 90 AD, a lot of people
had been murdered already. Yeah. And
they cried with a loud voice, saying,
"How long, O Lord, holy and true, does
thou not judge and avenge our blood on
them that dwell on the earth?" And white
robes were given unto every one of them.
And it was said unto them that they
should rest for yet here, oh, here's
that word, a little season. Look at
that. Pretty cool. Until their fellow
servants also and their brethren should
be
killed. As in they're not resurrected,
they're killed as they were should be
fulfilled. Where did you read little
season? Oh yeah. Yeah. They should rest
a little season. Wow. Rest a little
season. And so they're still going to
rest for a little season. Yeah. And so
people could say, "Well, that's during
the little season." No, the millennial
reign happens before the little season.
These people are still wanting the
resurrection. They're asking when is
this going to happen? When is our blood
going to be avenged? And he's telling
them it's going to be a while and that
until other people are killed. So until
everything should be fulfilled. So
they're waiting. So there's going to be
more that are killed. So these people
have yet to resurrect. It's 90 AD and
John's writing about it. And knowing
that these writings are going to go to
people and that's why he says at the end
of the book, if anyone changes the words
of this book, basically it's going to be
bad. they're going to rem have their
name removed out of the book of life.
And that's the one book in the Bible
that says that. I can't think of any
other book that tells you it's a
salvation issue if you if you alter the
words of this prophecy of this book
essentially. And so, Revelation is an
important one. It's you've got to
understand it is a big deal. If you're
saying that things have happened that
haven't, you're changing revelation. And
that's powerful. I don't want to be
wrong on this. I'm the same I'm in the
same boat as people who are saying that
a lot of this stuff has already happened
that when John was writing this. I don't
I haven't really fully looked into how
they
explain John's prophecies happening in
90 AD about and visions about things in
the future. Um but Peter tells us this
is something from Peter that he also
says in those times beloved I now write
unto you in both which I stir up your
pure minds by way of remembrance that ye
may be mindful of the words which were
spoken before by the holy prophets. And
so that's what we need to do. Go back to
the prophets. Study what they say. It's
confusing. It's like revelation, but
when you study the prophets, revelation
starts coming alive and making more
sense. The things the Messiah says make
a lot more sense. And so he's also
telling them to be mindful of the holy
prophets and of the commandment of us,
the apostles, of the Lord and Savior,
knowing this first, that there shall
come in the last day scoffers walking
after their own lust, saying, "Where is
the promise of his coming?" Wow. That's
what they're doing now. Where is he
coming? It's been a couple thousand
years came yet. He's knowing in those
last days that's what's going to happen.
People are going to be saying that.
They're saying that now. Yeah. It's not.
I don't think people were saying that in
their day because they literally saw him
come. Even those that pierced him. You
know, the guy that the Roman was like,
"Surely this is the son of God."
Um when Christ was killed on the cross,
an earthquake happened and thousands of
people were resurrected and witnessed in
the city. Then he
came he resurrected and hung out with
hundreds or thousands of people I can't
even remember. and uh was here for days,
like 40 days or something, and
then ascended back into the heavens.
Like they hundreds of people witnessed
this stuff.
Yeah. So why would they be saying, "Oh,
when's the sign of his
coming?" Dude, they saw like what he was
capable of. They wouldn't be saying that
kind of stuff.
Yeah, it's been a while. People are
thinking, "When's he coming?" But I I
know we're right there just like Peter
said. Be mindful of the prophets. And
look look at the the words though. I'm
going read this again.
Um where's it
at the known savior first? Hold
on. Oh, there it is. But beloved, be not
ignorant of this one thing. Be not
ignorant of this. That means understand
it. Don't be dumb about it. Understand
what I'm telling you. That one day is
with the Lord has a thousand years. in a
thousand years as one day. And that's
what we were talking about earlier. Some
of you may have missed that. Hosea
prophesied right before the Messiah came
about that exact same concept when he
said in the third day, we shall arise.
But what's going to happen before that
third day? Third millennial day, 3,000
years later or after the 2,000 year
mark, he says after two days, he will.
[Music]
Oh, closer. And so that stuff right
there, I mean, it's powerful. You got to
be ready. He's about to rise us up.
Yeah, I heard a little bit of
final card. Yeah, I'm I'm pulling up
your channel so I can promote it at the
end. I didn't know I was going to play
that song. Oh, yeah. It always does.
Sorry, I have it set to play Michael's
video right when it pops up. But yeah,
that that's something we're waiting for.
We're waiting for that third day. We're
approaching the third day, the third
millennial day, the new third millennial
day. Because when the Messiah came, the
calendar started over 0 to 1,000,
showing us that countdown that Hosea
talked about before the Messiah was
here. And so being healed, being
revived, and now we're about to be
raised up, and it's going to be the
seventh millennial day, but it's also
that new third day. And so I'm going to
see if I can show you a better look at
that. There you go. Adam dying back
there. He did not live his entire day.
He died that day just like Jubilees
tells us. Wow. Yeah. So cool stuff. I
know that's a lot. I don't want to cover
too much more because I know for the
sake of time, dude. Um clarity and we
can answer some questions. I know people
had some really
So somebody's saying we ignored some.
Let's see. I don't I haven't read
ignored. Can of truth. Will you actually
look at the verse I shared? You asked
for them and you ignore them. Uh I
shared like eight verses. Oh, well, I've
been in a live stream here with Josh. I
don't I couldn't see everything. Be
nice, guys. I know. I don't know what it
is about the I'm telling you, there's
something spiritual because you see a
lot of hate and anger, and that to me is
a very telling thing. I mean, like I
said, dude, my whole life I've been a
open-minded, truth-seeking skeptic.
That's how I got to where I'm at today.
I I wasn't raised to believe the stuff I
believe today. I I went into the
witchcraft world. I I did everything my
own way. And ultimately I came back to
the Bible because it was true. And I was
studying with a Baptist guy. I was
studying with Adventist. I was studying
with Jehovah's Witness. I was studying
with everybody. And I was just looking
at God's word and I'm like I was
literally studying with a Baptist guy.
And he was telling me now we believe in
the pre-trip rapture. And I said,
"Where's it at?" And he's like, "Well,
we're changing a moment in twinkle of an
eye." And I said, "Okay, I see that
verse, but I don't see that in some
timeline before our heads are cut off in
Revelation." You know, I was letting
God's word speak for itself. And I told
God, I said, "I believe." I was at a
point where I was like, "I believe you
exist. I believe prayer works. I believe
your your word is true. I'm so sick of
all the different denominations, all the
different beliefs. What does your word
say? I'm not going to believe anything
unless I see it in your word myself."
And I learned how to study line upon
line. And I hear a little there a little
precept upon precept by the mouth of two
or three witnesses and letting the word
of God interpret itself. And so now I
believe in all kinds of things that I
was never raised to believe. And it's it
is a narrow way and a lot of people
don't believe this in mainstream
Christianity. Um including stuff like
the Sabbath and flat earth and all that
kind of stuff. But when it comes to this
little season thing, I'm open to it.
I've looked into it and I've looked into
a lot of things with an open mind. Um
I'm trying to remember one of the other
things that Oh, lunar Sabbath. I looked
into that and almost believed it until I
started seeing reasons why it doesn't
add up. So, I'm open-minded and I I I
want to know the truth. And I just don't
see it here. I see so much against it. I
really don't I see some interesting
things that kind of make it, you know,
especially when you're looking for truth
and you see this for the first time,
you're like, "Oh, whoa. Wow. We could be
like finding out a big deception right
here, but it really just falls apart
when you look at prophecy. I mean,
prophecy really is the key. And I I put
everything in the balances.
If I see uh three verses that seem to
contradict 20, I'm going to study out
those three and see what what's going on
here. I'm going to look at the Greek and
the Hebrew. I'm going to try to really
look at it. And and usually that's the
issue. It's it's those couple that are
being misunderstood rather than the 20.
And that's how I I always study topics
like this out. And so you shown so many
things. I I kind of want to
review. The stars are here. They're
supposed to fall from heaven. The the
sky is supposed to open up like a a
scroll. And somebody in there said
that's why we have the Milky Way. Uh
that's why you see that it's a scar or
something.
Um but yeah, the the sky is supposed to
open up like a scroll. The kingdom of
heaven's supposed to be here. We don't
see it.
Um, there's supposed to be mortal
people. I guess all those people are in
hiding. I don't understand why anybody's
alive right now. If Christ returned, the
wicked are consumed by the brightness of
his coming. So why are we here? Why and
is is there any possibility of
salvation? If we're alive right now,
Christ already
returned. Your your faith is sealed. You
only have till Christ
returns. If you're dead righteous,
you'll be you'll be resurrected. If
you're alive righteous, you'll be caught
up to meet him in the air. There's no
verse that says, "Oh, you could be a
part of the third resurrection or
something." No, I don't see anything
that says that you could be
alive after the thousand year after
Christ returns and and come to
salvation. I
mean, um, what else? Yeah, that's the
ones I believe the ones that are getting
the leaves from the nations, the ones
that are going, like it says in prophecy
and keeping the feast of tabernacles,
they're going to be a righteous people,
but I feel like they're going to be
they're they're not the ones who are
resurrected like that were a part.
That's why it says blessed and holy are
those who are part of that first
resurrection, right? Because they're not
going to see death. Like they're not
going to experience death at all. Like
if you're a part of that, like you're
not going to experience dying the second
death cuz the second death is that final
punishment that happens after Gog and
Magog once they have all of that and
they're all destroyed by fire because
the Gog and Magog is an actual area. And
so um where that's at is very close to
where Armageddon is. It's the same
thing. So the long season that we're in
versus the little season, they're
gathering people together to fight.
There's a threat from above and there's
a threat from the ground. There's a
punishment of hell and there's a
punishment of fire. And so you have
these two things with just like Egypt.
It's the same goal. So you have to
remember that the enem is doing the same
thing over and over and over. So it's
going to feel like it's a season that
we're in of deception because every
season with the enemy involved is a
season of deception. We've seen that
with Egypt. We've seen that I mean all
throughout the word deceiving the
father's people. And now here we are
again being deceived about aliens and
what's above us. Threats from above. And
that's where the threat's coming from.
The threat they're going to say is
coming from above. When we get raised up
there to meet them in the air, we're
going to be a part of that threat. I
believe they're going to be like, "What
is this? What's going on?" You know,
look at all this. This is this is not
good. We need to unite just like they
just did with Operation Steadfast
Defender where they united with 90,000
troops. You know, like they're not doing
this for fun. They're doing it because
they know they know their clock's
ticking. They know what they're going to
do and they're going to fulfill the
father's will just like Pharaoh did. And
they're going to have their sorcerers
and their people do some tricks, some
good ones. You know, when the when the
staff actually turned into a serpent
when the Egyptians and the sorc the
sorcerers and the magicians and all them
came together, took three group three
groups of people to um sort of replicate
it, but they didn't fully replicate it.
Why? Because the staff of Aaron
swallowed theirs up. Theirs couldn't do
that. They got eaten. Um but they used
unclean spirits to work. The book of
Jubilees tells us that they used unclean
spirits. They were working with them to
do this stuff that you guys are teaching
deception. Yeah, we got we got three
thumbs down. So, if if you guys are
watching and and you do agree that we're
not in the little season, but go ahead
and give this video a thumbs up. Really
helps this video got get into the
algorithm. It's a easy, simple, and free
way to support this channel. So, we
really appreciate those thumbs up. I
appreciate the thumbs down too because
it actually helps algorithm too. Any
kind of interaction with the comments,
good or bad, or the thumbs up, thumbs
down. Both of them are great. So, just
click either one actually. Yeah. So, we
got four thumbs down. So, I am curious
to see how many people believe this
because it comes up all the time.
Yeah, it's it's a it's a it's a big
thing. There's a lot of videos and I've
gone through them and it's a lot of the
same stuff which and I don't see a focus
on prophecy and that's what breaks my
heart that the prophecy aspect is not a
foundation like Peter said be mindful of
the prophets. It's more of a it's more
of um a flashy it's very flashy. There's
lots of beautiful structures that we've
repurposed and that it's like as if like
during the millennial reign the
structures being built are going to be
made and they might be nice during the
millennial reign. I don't know. But a
lot of the times when those buildings I
see the imagery and I go and look at
those buildings there's like a big
Freemason logo because masons work with
stone and that's why they're called
masons. They they go all the way back to
the Tower of Babel and masonry is a big
deal with the evil ones. put things in
stone that they want to remain for you
to see. I believe that even fallen
angels could build that stuff, man.
Yeah. I mean that and a lot of these
things are pre- flood. I think that
pyramids could be pre flood. Um writings
and stone were found by the children of
mo of um Moses or not Moses, Noah. And
they sinned and and they sinned because
they saw those writings on the stone and
it's like here's this wisdom that's been
hidden. It survived the flood. Let's
look and to see what it says. And then
you start getting demonized and start
summoning. They start doing things and
sinning because of what's in stone. And
what type of, you know, what is Yeshua
referred to as? Somebody said this and
it stuck um in the comments. They said,
Yeshua is referred to as the stone the
builders rejected. What type of builders
work with stones? Masons. Masons. Yeah.
And I was like, that makes sense to me.
And guess who? How the Illuminati
formed? Jesuits and Freemasons came
together in 1776.
Wow,
dude. Yeah. I mean, some more of these
things that I'd like to know. Somebody
asked if I would be willing to go live
with somebody that believes we're in the
little season. Absolutely. I I mean, I
want to see the proofs. I got questions.
You know, we're not supposed to have any
sea. We're not The Mount of Olives is
supposed to be slip split in half. I
mean, there's a lot of things that are
not were
not of peace. When was that?
Yeah, man. So, dude, I really appreciate
you coming on and sharing this. And this
was really cool because this felt like
Bible study. Like, there's there's
people out there that are like, "Oh, you
guys ever talk about his evil and
conspiracies and why don't you talk
about Jesus?" And this was straight up
Bible study right here. And um you know,
we weren't we weren't saying like, "Look
what Katy Perry did and all this stuff."
It's like this is what some people
believe the Bible says and this is what
we believe. Let's study it out. And that
I love it, dude. This was this was
really awesome. Feel the spirit moving
with this one because it has to. People
have to go and be spearled on this
stuff. Don't be personled. You know, the
the best translation. People always ask
me, "What is it?" It's the Holy Spirit
translation where the Holy Spirit's
telling you what his word actually says
because it will be confusing. We're
reading things that have been handed
down and translated many times with bias
after people who are mankind, you know,
and so the Holy Spirit is here for a
reason. It's a gift to disperse that
confusion in your mind. And that's what
it does. Anytime you're confused, pray.
And he'll go, "Here's your clarity." And
it comes in. And I'm glad I did that
because I was I was buying into the
predous type of view, starting to
probably about six years ago because I
didn't know prophecy. I didn't know
prophecy. I was seeing some of those key
verses and going, "Oh my goodness, my
heart's racing." You know, like I think
this is where we are. And and it really
does. It'll take hold of you. And if you
don't step back, pray, and seek, and
thankfully, the father sent me on that
understanding of the millennial day
aspect like Peter talked about a
thousand years as a day. Otherwise, I
would be probably leaning towards that,
and it would be it would cause a lot of
confusion. And I've had so much peace
going the other direction.
Amen, bro. Well, thank you so much,
dude, for coming on. We gota we got to
keep doing some more shows together
sometime. I know you and I have both
been super busy, but every time we come
together, it seems like uh a lot of
people just like it. So, there there's
132 people in here, usually we average
like 80. So, um thanks for tuning in
everybody. I know this was a lengthy
word study. If you missed some, please
go back, look at the verses. There's a
lot that we've covered and I tried to
condense as much as I could, but I had
to break my slides up into three
separate presentations because they're
all over a hundred slides each. There's
a lot of of verses in there, precursors
to, you know, location, things like
that. So, go through and I can even try
to share my links maybe um for my
presentations. If you guys ever have any
questions about my presentations or want
the actual links to the presentations
themselves, I can send you the Google
slide presentations, send us an email at
flatearthbros@gmail.com.
Oh, the old school name the creation
standard. We also have a homeschool
program for creationist if you're into
creation science proving all things. We
I'm a science teacher by trade and
decided to teach students the truth
about creation from a life science and
earth science perspective.com.
Yeah,
creationstandard.com. And so classes are
almost done. Sadly, we're getting near
the end of the first ever online virtual
school experience and it's been a
blessing. So, if you're interested in
that, starting up next semester in the
fall or I guess September, September
second.
Yeah, you can click there. You can
register now and pick a class. We have
earth science and life science. And so,
children of all ages, adults included.
We have some adults that have joined our
classes that follow along. And I'm
learning more than
anybody because I'm I decided to do four
classes and I did not realize how big of
a blessing it would be to me. I've
learned so much more this year than I've
ever learned in all my years as a
teacher doing creation standards. So,
it's a blessing. And one of my students
today, it it made me about cry. She
said, I I told them we're doing our
yearbook pictures and she said, um, I
don't want this to end, you know, like
this has been a life experience. And I'm
like, wow, that's amazing, dude. You
know how many kids just hate school? I
know. And they get sad when we go on
breaks, which is amazing. I'm like,
they're the best students I've ever had.
So, if you're interested in that sort of
thing, go there. You can register now
and it'll let us know how many to
prepare for because we don't know what
to expect until Awesome.
creationstandard.com. Check it out,
guys. You get to be taught real science
by a real science teacher and not that
fake garbage that's out there. And if
you guys don't know about Josh's
channel, Flat Earth, Founded Earth,
sorry, founded Earth Brothers on
YouTube. And uh this video got 553,000
views. So awesome. That was our first
ever video on the channel, too, which is
funny.
whatever.
There's so many that channel out of
anger. I had another channel back in the
day that was like a small channel and I
got in trouble at work by my
administrator for talking about the
firmament in a in a video on a small
channel and I was like, "That's it. I'm
gonna make a new channel." So, we made
this. Here we are now. That's awesome.
Well, dude, thank you so much, man. Uh,
hope you have a good weekend and thank
you everybody for being here and do
we'll catch you on the flip side. I'm
going to sign out here. Thank you guys
so much for being here. I hope this was
a blessing to you. If you got questions,
please drop them in the comments. We do
read all these comments and if you
agree, if you disagree, click a thumbs
up, click a thumbs down, tell us uh how
we're deceiving people or tell us how
you agree. Either way, we'd love to hear
from you. Also, let us know if there's
any topics you'd like to hear about. And
uh hopefully we'll have Josh on again
sometime soon. Give this video a thumbs
up, click subscribe, click the
notification bell so you won't miss
another video. Share this with all your
family and friends who might be hearing
about this because we got to know how to
defend the truth when these deceptive
things come our way. You know, sometimes
these things can just take you off guard
and you don't want to be deceived in
these last days. That's the one thing
Jesus said. Do not be deceived. So, if
you'd like to support this ministry, you
can do so by going to candidtruth.org.
We got some digital ways to give on
there. If you guys like t-shirts, we got
some cool t-shirts that we get a little
bit of profit from. And I'm wearing one
right now, wearing this retro candid
brain shirt. It's all about the brain on
this channel. It's cool to use your
brain. We love you guys. We thank you.
We can't do this without you. Thanks to
all you supporters out there. We can't
do this without you. And we really mean
that from the bottom of our hearts. We
love you. We'll see you next time on
Candid Truth.